[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
was there news that happened yesterday
sorry I didn't catch it
doesn't seem like anything big is going
on in the world of politics
breaking news
Grandpa's diaper is full it is full of
[__] [__] just like he is um and just
in the Trump aide Walt not to I think
it's how you say his last name and I'm
not the 100 sure
um but he's a trump aide he was with him
in the white house
um he is also and apparently he's one of
the ones that was moving the the boxes
and in this key moment of Espionage uh
he seems to have been indicted uh as
well in this case that's the
announcement I'm sure we'll get more
details as they come
now I want to go over some of these
charges because there's seven of them I
believe
um I don't know exactly how many counts
there are of each of these charges but
willful retention of National Defense
information uh let's see that carries 10
years if convicted conspiracy to
obstruct Justice now here's where I want
to go with this last night I was and
we'll get to the rest of these charges
and really we're going to find out and
have confirmation of these charges
eventually I don't know that we'll
actually see some of the evidence in the
um in the indictment because this has to
do with classified information
um there's a video or excuse me a
recording of trump uh that CNN has
released the transcripts of of him
saying he knew he knew they were
classified and that he couldn't
declassify him at that moment apparently
this is uh
this recording was retaliation against
Millie General milley because he [__]
hates him now wouldn't that just
wouldn't that just be rich that Donald
Trump goes down with the evidence before
us because he's trying to seek revenge
on someone he doesn't like hmm seems
kind of funny I don't know just saying
look here's the thing
last night I was in the Twitter space
and these [__] chuckleheads were
arguing over rather he can classify or
declassify documents folks that ain't
got [__] to do with this and if you're
looking at these charges you know that
this ain't got [__] to do with
classified not classified rather he can
magically classify them with his brain
or not when he could when he couldn't if
it if he did just by taking them I mean
there's all sorts of [__] stupid
theories out there on the right about
why this isn't illegal because
he Declassified them this is really
stupid that's this dumb argument that's
where they want to land the argument the
argument is this and this is the
argument that the doj and Jack Smith are
going to make and it's very clear about
these [__] charges
it has to do with obstruction and intent
what was his intent
of the obstruction so you commit a
[__] felony right obstruction
and your intent was criminal that's the
whole [__] point it ain't got nothing
to do with rather he magically
classified Declassified him with his
mind and ain't got [__] to do with that
and that's the point of why why Mike
Pence isn't going to be charged in his
documents case why Joe Biden ain't gonna
be charged in his documents case because
there isn't the intent of obstruction
you [__] there is not Criminal
Intent of obstruction let's keep going
here another another charges withholding
a document a record there's 20-year
sentence with that uh correct corruptly
concealing a document
a record 20 years for that concealing a
document in a federal investigation 20
years for that a scheme to conceal five
years for that false statements and
misrepresentations
five years for that so there's I mean
there's hundreds of years of uh
sentencing here
if a judge so may wish after he's
convicted
now here's the reality okay we knew this
was coming we knew it because he was
[__] his pants on true social for
the last year over this documents and
over his obstruction and again it's
about intent and obstruction those two
words keep saying them to these mugga
idiots intent and obstruction intent and
obstruction
because they're gonna try to get you in
a debate about if he can declassify
documents or not and with these charges
it is clear that it's not what the [__]
happened it has nothing to do with
rather he Des classify them or not
they clearly have evidence that he knew
they were not Declassified
and CNN has the [__] transcript now
here's the thing that's going to piss
you off the audience and the American
people
here's the thing that's going to piss
you off because Tuesday he's gonna go be
arraigned on these federal charges these
felony counts that could possibly hold
decades in prison
is that he's gonna walk free
okay I want I want I want you to be
clear on this he's gonna walk into that
Courthouse he's gonna be arraigned
they're gonna let him walk free
that's right and he's gonna still be out
there
that's selling his [__] lies and
pushing his lies to his base and they're
gonna continue to do this
and he has secured the nomination
this has secured him the nomination
DeSantis Hey Ron you might as well drop
out you're done buddy last night when
you tweeted
in support of Donald Trump you're
[__] done man
Chris Christie Mainland some punches but
who gives a [__] about Chris Christie or
Hutchinson who gives a [__] they're all
done
listen the Republican party does not
give a [__]
if their guy is a crooked [__]
criminal they don't care
matter of fact it seems as if they
prefer it
because that's truly what they want I
mean this morning Jim trustee who
breaking news Jim trustee is no longer
on the legal team was on Fox News saying
that that this indictment
this indictment was done right now as a
distraction from the hunter Biden five
million dollar thing whatever the [__]
that is whatever lie that is that they
manufactured
that's right manufactured lies about the
Biden regime
it's the exact opposite Jim trustee is
no longer on the legal team by the way I
don't know if he's just gonna be going
on Fox News and spreading more lies
folks let them investigate the bidens
let them talk about it the more they
talk about the bidens the more they show
that there's no evidence
of crime the worse it's going to be for
them
that's right the worse it will be for
them folks no one woke up this morning
enraged that Donald Trump is being
indicted in South Florida they're like
yeah that makes sense even Republicans
are like yeah that makes sense I mean
Jesus Christ there was there was people
anchors on Newsmax posting videos on the
internet last night saying well he'll
win from a prison cell and then he can
pardon himself that's what they're gonna
say
Mike Pence might as well drop out
whoever that guy is from North Dakota
Vivek will stay in Vivek is being paid
by Trump to be his opponent I believe
that's my belief I mean from the
evidence that I can see
Nikki Haley might as well drop out Scott
get out it's over it's over
and that's the weirdest part about all
this it's not surprising that he
committed crime it's not surprising that
this [__] chucklehead decided that he
was going to get out classified
documents to show people of how he was
going to seek revenge on Millie because
it was all Millie's fault or whatever
the [__] it was about these plans that I
ran
it's not surprising
that he did these things
is it and if it is surprising to you
maybe you're not living in in the quite
the reality that you need to be
the the craziest part the most
surprising thing
and the reason why we live in such a
weird timeline
is that this makes him the king of their
party
folks any other time in modern American
history
if a presidential candidate was being
charged with these types of charges
and the evidence being laid
at their feet for it
they would be absolutely [__] roasted
they would lose all support all backing
not just not just for money
not just from the party not just from
sitting politicians
but from the constituency
but they truly believe
because he has deluded them and they are
a cult
that he can win
that somehow he is popular in this
country
this is the big [__] lie you know
they call the big lie about how he lied
about it I won I won it was rigged it
was rigged against me I'm a big [__]
baby boo hoo
the big [__] lie
in this country and really all around
the world is that half the country
supports him
is that he has majority support in this
country get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense
and maybe maybe we'll see
large swaths of people who go and vote
for him
in the general election against Joe
Biden based on affiliation
but folks
this turkey is done
it's done all we have to do is do the
work that's it
we just have to do the work
because Jack Smith and the doj and the
special counsel
and their team is definitely done the
work
on making sure this motherfucker's held
accountable
and that's the good news here right I
mean there's going to be a ton of stuff
that's going to piss you off because
he's not in jail he's not in an orange
jumpsuit they haven't locked him up he's
still out lying I mean this morning he's
talking about Walt Malta on true social
which Walt Malta may be a witness
eventually which is witness tampering
to some account maybe who knows he could
there's could be superseding indictments
and crimes that he's committed since
he's been indicted if you don't think
that this guy's gonna tamper with
Witnesses you're a [__] idiot
but it's gonna piss you off when he's
not behind bars It's Gonna Make You
[__] infuriated when this guy doesn't
have an orange jumpsuit on her handcuffs
around his wrist
but you have to pay attention and stay
focused
we are Trump's jury
do not get too mired
in when the trial will happen when he
will or won't go to prison make sure you
stay focused on the real conviction here
make sure you stay focused on where the
decision will lie and that is with you
the people
we are the most important jury
we are the most important conviction
it is us the people the government the
Republic
our shining City on the hill
that get to the side rather Donald Trump
goes away or not
It Is Us
and we must stay together in this
pro-democracy coalition
so direct your strategic outrage
appropriately
because they're gonna back him I mean
think about this let me give you one
good example Josh Hawley who is going to
run as you sitting United States senator
in Missouri he's a sitting United States
Senator
he was complaining that the people in
power
are somehow getting at Donald Trump here
he is people in power he's a sitting
United States Senator
and he's supporting Grandpa Poopypants
in his effort to lie and Gaslight the
American people
that somehow somehow it's a Witch Hunt
that these crimes that are obviously
been committed
are not what you think they are and it's
just those people in power you know
those people that we elect
Josh Hawley is people in power
he's going to be running in 2024.
likely against maybe possibly Lucas
Koontz
in Missouri Lucas Koontz is going to run
on the Democratic ballot he seems like
the front runner maybe I should have
Lucas on the show and ask him about this
particular topic
but this is just one example of how
we're going to use this as a wedge to
make sure the American people do not
elect these [__] treasonous [__]
again
can you imagine if we woke up this
morning
think about this just like since we live
in an alternative reality anyways
can you imagine if you woke up this
morning
and there was news
that in the state of Illinois
Barack Obama was being charged
with seven charges
holding decades and decades and decades
a prison time
their [__]
whole universe would be melting in joy
and it would be all over oh my God
Democrats this Democrats that rig blah
blah blah I mean they're trying to make
something out of this fake ass 5 million
dollar transaction they keep talking
about if and you know that it's all
[__] because they're saying it
but can you imagine if that alternate
reality existed
it doesn't exist and the reason why is
because
Barack Obama
Joe Biden [__] even Mike Pence doesn't
have Criminal Intent when it comes to
these documents
and the only reason why we have this
situation in the first place is because
we were derelict in our duty folks in
2016 we were derelict and our duty
to make sure that someone
it's a big of a buffoon
as Donald Trump
did not enter
into a very important role in our
democracy
we were derelict in our duty
and I'll tell you that that is where the
rubber is going to meet the road
in 2024. rather we are derelict in our
duty as the jury
because we have that opportunity
right now
to engage in our democracy to point and
aim our strategic outrage
all the way down the ballot
with the example of Josh Hawley Josh
Hawley is going to support Donald Trump
to The Bitter End
don't you remember
that [__] coward he was encouraging
Trump's Nazi Vineland insurrectionist
with his white power fist
and then he ran away from him
when no one was looking quote unquote
that's right it's the same thing
you know who these people are we know
who they are now they're not hiding it
Jesus Christ Marjorie Taylor green
yesterday went into a skiff and
immediately came out took notes of what
the [__] she's seen in the Skip and then
went on TV and said it out loud
and you and you're still wondering if
Donald Trump is showing people who
shouldn't see classified information
classified information get the [__] out
of here with this [__] you people
are full of garbage
this is a trash you are if you think
that [__]
it is clear it is clear that this is not
the party of Law and Order and it never
has been
this is this is their personality
do as I say not as I do
for laws for thee not for me
we have a two-tier justice system and
I'm mad that it's that two-tier is not
protecting me anymore
it is clear what the Republican party
wants in this country
and you should be excited about it
do you know how [__] easy it is going
to be to beat the pants off these
fascist
do you have any idea I mean I hope
Rhonda Santa stays in the race I hope
Chris Christie stays in I hope they stay
in I mean any reasonable person would
get out at this point
I mean Ron DeSantis destroyed any chance
he has of winning the Republican
nomination
destroyed it
torched it it's done it's over with
he can't turn it back he can't undo what
he said no matter what the charges are
no matter where this investigation
leaves
leads excuse me
but we need him to stay in
oh [__] yeah we want him to stay in I
hope Chris Christie beats the [__] out
of Donald Trump
over the next six seven eight months
until he can't run no more and then he
drops out
beats the hell out of him about these
these charges
gives us tons of content to run against
Donald Trump in the general election
because that's what it's about folks
because I keep getting this [__] on the
right and you know some people you know
they they dance around and oh oh okay so
here's the thing here's one of the
arguments also that the right wing is
gonna throw at you
it's all political yeah it's all
political you [__] idiots
it is political yes everything's
political
everything what do you think the [__]
investigation from Congress of Jim Comer
and Jim Jordan into Hunter Biden and
Biden what do you don't think that's
political you don't think they're trying
to damage the Democratic candidate get
the [__] out of here and if you have
anyone encouraging encouraging members
of Congress to weaponize the government
like Jim Jordan and Jim Comer are
against the president of the United
States
so that way they can bang up his
candidacy
well [__]
what do you think that is other than
political so yeah it's [__] political
let's do it
let's have this [__] political fight
why not and any any [__] leftist or
democrat or
any liberal out there that's that's oh
it's it's not political it's just the
law it's just what happens
[__] that lean into it you goddamn right
it's political let's have this political
fight
let's let the American people decide
whether we're going to have a criminal
running our [__] country or someone
who's you know just reaches the bar of
decency Jesus [__] Christ
and we got to make this decision again
we already made this decision
but it's you [__] manga who
won't [__] change your minds about
what reality is and what it isn't
it's not our fault it's not our problem
that you can't let go of your orange
Mussolini Jesus until you drink the
Kool-Aid that we can't do anything about
you being in a cult
there's nothing we can do about it the
only thing we can do is to politicize it
to get to get you [__] to wake
up and smell a Kool-Aid
what else are we supposed to do that's
the arena we're in Jesus Christ have you
watched Grandpa poopy pants lose his
mind on true social hold rallies well
cancel rallies pretending he's gonna
hold rallies
come on give his stupid [__] hostage
political videos his campaign videos and
[__] out of here man and you don't think
this is political it is absolutely 100
political and we should lean into it
and the what about ISM fine whatever you
want to play what about ISM about Hunter
Biden's fake ass laptop and no
transactions that ever happened in the
history of ever with Joe Biden fine
let's do it let's do it [__] let's
fight it out in the political Arena
let's do it because I'm highly confident
if we have that fight uh as a political
fight not a legal one in the courts the
courts will handle that I'm talking
about the political fight we can win
this
we will win it every single time
and we will continue to win we just have
to do the work that's all we have to do
is engage in our democracy believe in
the institutions
don't play their stupid [__] games
when they want to have conversations
around rather Donald Trump can
declassify documents with his mind or
not get to the [__] facts get
straight to it and let them fall on
their lies
if they're gonna set the rates out to
step on let them [__] step on them
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em
that's what I say politicize the [__]
out of this you goddamn right it's about
politics you [__] ain't right honored
[__] percent
it's about politics let's do it
let's do it every single weekday right
here on the Tony Michaels podcast boy is
it going to be a good show we got
bonehead of the week I don't really it's
like bonehead of the century some people
were voting for Donald Trump and some
other people were voting for Donald
Trump then there's another guy on the
polls named Donald Trump I think Gabe
zinj has rigged this election uh for
today's bonetta League it's Friday you
know that's the day we do bonehead of
the week here on the Tony Michaels
podcast don't go anywhere it's going to
be exciting speaking of stepping on
rakes make sure you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com show us some
support there if you can let them eat
rake merch is now available
also you can grab some [__] Pro
Pride merch the the audience here miss
loveseek had the idea of doing a pride
[__] on logo and the audience loved the
idea
uh in the chat so Gabe Sanchez made a
[__] Pride logo so go to store.com
that's store.donymichaels.com
you can get your your merch there and
thank you for the support of the show
also also if you want to support the
show the best way to do it for free is
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
right now hit subscribe it's free to
watch us on YouTube every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific YouTube Twitter and
twitch and also you can watch us on
Facebook did you know that if you still
have a Facebook account you can go to at
the Tony Michaels that's at the Tony
Michaels involves on Facebook and if
you're watching on Twitch hello from
twitch go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels you
can follow us over there and we
appreciate all the support on all the
platforms no matter which one you're on
WE highly enjoy having you here in the
chat now if you want to listen to the
show just the audio version don't fret
in the afternoon I download it on every
or I upload it you should download it on
every single directory Apple Spotify
Google it's free 99 to download the Tony
Michaels podcast
and share with a friend it's free to
share it too you just you know share it
you send it
oh man
what a great Friday it's been a great
week Pat Robinson is [__] dead and
Donald Trump is indicted don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome
back to the show boy it's a [__] show
just getting uh some information here it
looks like the reporting earlier Jim
trusky
and John Rawley
the attorneys that were representing
Grandpa poopy pants
in the documents and January 6
investigation
have resigned
they weren't fired they resigned at
least that's what we know publicly uh
Scott McFarland has it here in a tweet
this is the this is the quote from the
statement of the attorneys oh well maybe
hang on
it's a lot of news really fast so I got
the wrong one
oh boy it's gonna be uh flash news
probably all all day today now as we
tick through this so if you do have
updates or anything you can throw them
in the chat there and I try to try to
get the moderators uh maybe even
um
um you know and they they can trying to
send us something if we've got
um and I know I know they're going to be
paying attention to to any kind of
breaking news but it's probably going to
be all day today it's just uh it's
getting crazy but here's Scott mcfarling
um flash Trump attorneys and resigning
this is the quote this morning we
tendered our resignations as counseled
to the to president Trump and we'll no
longer represent him on either the
indicted case or the January 6
investigation you know it's not a
and then you know what it doesn't smell
like a good idea or a good thing when as
soon as you're indicted
your attorney's like I'm out [__] nope
not gonna have anything to do with that
[__] oh man son of a [__]
oh boy so um we have that uh here's
here's more uh Scott has reported here
from the uh from the statement
I treat this as more uh here's the quote
it has been an honor to have spent the
last year defending him
has it though you lying [__]
man come on it's been an honor come on
man the [__] out of here no one
No One Believes that [__] that it's been
an honor they go on to say and we know
he'll be Vindicated in his battle
against Biden's administration's
partisan weaponization the American
justice system listen I know it's it's
they they like to throw the word Biden
in there because they're gonna do the
what about ISM which great great
uh Margie Margie sending me messages
misspelled horror yeah it's been a
horror to his last year defending him oh
my God you got to be [__] [__] me
and honor my ass oh boy well um he also
put out a video I think
um let me see if I can find that while
we wait for Gabe Sanchez Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us here in just a little
bit
um we will be doing that well let's
let's read some of Grandpa's statements
from this morning this is from let's see
this is from about
um this is from about uh half an hour
ago or so he says I've just learned that
the thugs
quote from the Department of Department
of Injustice will be indicting a
wonderful man Walt nada
a member of the U.S Navy who's served
proudly with me in the White House
return to retired as Senior Chief and
then transitioned into private life as a
personal aide
he has done a fantastic job of
committing crime apparently he's done a
wonderful job of commending crime oh
Walt
they are trying to destroy his life
yeah because he committed crime with his
conspiracy do I mean not like the lives
of so many others hoping that he will
say bad things about Trump quote unquote
he is strong Brave and a great Patriot
the FBI and doj are corrupt again and I
think Trump is telling Walt here he's
like oh those are nice legs be ashamed
if something happened to him let me say
something bad about Trump
ah he's the he's the worst mobster in
the world isn't he I'm dead serious he's
the worst [__] mobster in the world
no mobster in the world is gonna sit
there on possibly on recording
saying the exact opposite of his defense
that he was trying to make the entire
time what the [__] get the [__] out of
here here's another statement
um this is this is uh this is this is
his statement about Jim trustee
uh for purposes of fighting the greatest
Witch Hunt of all times now moving to
the Florida courts which is kind of the
news right and everyone's kind of
worried about this like uh judge Cannon
is gonna drew the straw for this which
again listen when they start telling you
that all this is a [__] Witch Hunt
and all that [__] do you think Jack
Smith ever in the history of ever would
would want Eileen Cannon as the judge
who drew the straw no that just proves
that it's not [__] all rigged up
against him that it's not a Witch Hunt
it's just how it works it's how it works
for me it's how it works for you it's
how it works for everyone else and
that's how it should work for this
[__]
yes if they can do this to Donald Trump
they certainly can do it to you and if
they can do it to you they certainly
should be able to [__] do it to
Donald Trump
he's not in a different class you
[__] keep bitching about a
two-tier justice system but what it
really is again is that you're terrified
that your level of Justice your two-tier
your second tier your privileged tier is
not protecting you anymore that's what
you're [__] pissed off about
um he goes on to say here
uh I will be represented by Todd Blanche
and a firm to be named later in other
words he has no one else that will
defend him
um I want to thank Jim trustee and John
Rawley for their work
in other words they I I'm glad that they
helped me try to obstruct justice but
they didn't do it good enough obviously
but they were against a very dishonest
corrupt evil and sick group of people
that likes which is not as seen before
will announce additional lawyers in the
coming days meaning he doesn't he
doesn't have anybody that will defend
him that's it when will Joe Biden be
indicted
of as many crimes against the nation
Maga
oh man what a what a [__] whiny
little [__] man when will Joe Biden be
indicted okay so again going back to the
whole Alex
okay sure yeah certainly whatever Donald
Trump's making it political if that's
what you want to say fine I don't give a
[__] let's make it political let's have
this political fight let's fight this
out in the election Joe Biden
reaches the bar of decency and again
he's much higher than that bar but he at
least reaches the bar of [__] decency
to be the president United States and
then you have on the other hand you have
the Republicans orange Mussolini Jesus
that they can't seem to shake even
though they hate that [__]
because he is a loser
good [__] em let them have him
and let him keep talking about Joe Biden
and the crimes that don't exist against
Joe Biden fine [__] them keep going
keep doing it that's that's great for
our politicization it's great for
engaging people in democracy
it's great you're not going to be able
to bring anything to the table guess
what the Department of Justice did
yesterday they brought it to the table
and the grand jury says yep
that's crime seven [__] charges who
knows how many [__] counts there are
there could be several counts on each
one of these charges we don't know that
yet we'll find out on Tuesday
oh man it's gonna be a super Tuesday and
then
oh super Tuesday God damn
hell man here's the full list of charges
if you want to see them
and the counts and which statute and
then excuse me the charges which statute
and then what the actual penalty maximum
penalty is
if you want to see those again that's
will for retention of National Defense
information uh 10-year sentence and some
these are maximums now conspiracy to
obstruct Justice 20-year sentence Max
withholding a document a record 20 years
Max corruptly concealing a document a
record 20 years Max concealing a
document in federal investigation 20
years Max scheme to conceal five years
false statements of representation five
years now again this doesn't mean you'll
be convicted on every single one of
these charges and it doesn't mean that
these are the only charges that will be
brought okay
it just it just didn't oh some people
are pointing out Texas Paul and um and I
don't know how many of you said this
right I'll admit it Texas Paul was wrong
he said Friday he said the day it was
yesterday
no Texas Paul said this week he did say
this week and the only reason why I was
I was uh saying that it could be this
week next week months is because there
was no clear indication there was no
clear indicator that they were going to
make this this case to the grand jury in
Miami
it was unclear but it's clear they had a
case already developed and it's clear
when they presented to the grand jury
that grand jury did not hesitate at all
so it seems pretty Loctite it seems that
their material evidence in the documents
case at least
is very good now um some people are
wondering about the January 6 case 2
which I mean I still think that we have
um
we're still going to see charges out of
the DC jurisdiction right and that that
may be why Jack Smith decided to charge
him in the uh jurisdiction that he did
because where it happened now also a lot
of people
manga is going to do this too how can
the special counsel charge him in South
Florida when he's in DC well the special
counselor can charge him in [__]
California if he wants
if Donald Trump committed crime in
California Arizona
maybe Georgia possibly Pennsylvania
maybe even like
um Michigan right in this January 6th
game Wisconsin hmm I mean some of those
States sound like they're going Nevada
Nevada could be one of them I don't know
maybe they're maybe there's federal
crimes that happen that the special
counsel will overturn
those rocks uh for the January 6
investigation
and maybe there'll be federal charges
out of those jurisdictions we know Scott
Perry has worked very very hard to make
sure the feds do not see the evidence
about January 6 it's in his cell phone
uh Congressman Scott Perry from
Pennsylvania so maybe maybe just maybe
Scott Perry and Donald Trump will be
charged in a jurisdiction in
Pennsylvania who the [__] knows we don't
know
I mean all these things are very
possible
there could be people who out that are
out there that help plan the January 6
Insurrection help pay for buses help bus
people to D.C
to commit a violent Insurrection who
knows who knows it could go it could go
well beyond DC and that's what the
special counsel is charged to do
the special counsel can charge in all
these jurisdictions I'm no [__]
lawyer
I'm the legal scholar but I I don't need
to be to know that that's the point of a
special counsel
is to un untie them from the politics of
the Department of Justice and make sure
the crimes that have been committed are
done
and they get those they get those
prosecutions that's the whole point of a
special counsel Jesus Christ we watch
watch durum do the same stupid [__]
[__] now he fell on his face
because it was all based on lies and the
narrative that they wanted to create
that wasn't real and that's why he
failed miserably
John Durham against Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton and her emails what do
you think we're gonna hear about them
why Joe Biden should go to prison
because Hillary had emails or something
about Benghazi you think you think
they're gonna eventually work in a
situation where they're like yeah
Joe Biden Benghazi put him in jail
really you think we'd get there I think
they're gonna get there
I think they are I think the American
people like what the [__] are you
[__] me
this is the best they got
it is the best they have though isn't it
oh my God it's great this morning don't
don't don't hesitate
to Wade in the marketeers folks do not
hesitate to do it okay here is the um
uh Rachel bittickoffer uh she yeah she's
a great friend of the show
um I was gonna try to have her on this
morning she couldn't she couldn't join
us I hopefully she'll join us sometime
next week maybe Monday
um cat turd
on Twitter
tweets Democrats can't win unless they
cheat
oh man oh man so again this is the whole
Narrative of oh it's all political yeah
sure okay yeah we're cheating sure fine
whatever go for it yeah we're gonna
cheat to win that's that's how we win
that's how it ends we're gonna win
[__] [__] so Rachel responds to him
this is hilarious Rachel says now
pretend Joe Biden did this and she she's
giving the um uh the the
the transcripts of these tapes let me
let me show you some of these
um I believe this is probably important
here is from CNN the transcripts and and
it's hard to read right because it is
transcripts of him talking so it's
difficult to [__] make sense of it
because he's a [__] idiot right
because it's a recording and it's 2021
here's the the first quote well with
Millie um let me see that I'll show you
an example he said that I wanted to
attack Iran isn't that amazing I have a
big pile of papers uh oh he's got a big
pile of papers remember how they said oh
he doesn't have piles of papers laying
around his office that was all that was
all done up by the FBI they took they
set it up like that and took pictures
yeah okay even he's admitting with his
own words that he has big piles of paper
I'm a [__] idiot this thing just came
up look this was him they presented me
this he's showing documents right he's
got to classify documents in his [__]
hand
what he's saying this because he's
showing it to him
this is off the Record he's talking to a
reporter
if that's if you're not clear on that
he's talking to a reporter here because
he says this is off the Record but and
he continues to say here let's see if we
can go to the next one
oh my God
[__] chucklehead
he says they presented me this
this was him
he's like he's like got the paper in his
hand he's like
here it is just like Marjorie Taylor
Green's like I went into the skiff and
as soon as I came out I wrote down all
the classified information on this piece
of paper and I'm holding it up in front
of the screen so you can see all the
classified information and then I'm just
going to tell it to you out loud too
that's cool I mean you know it's not
illegal or anything oh my God he says
this was the depart the defense
department and him meaning Millie we
looked at some meaning plans to attack
Iran again he doesn't
he can't [__] talk he can't finish a
sentence can't make sense of any of this
you can't he's a chucklehead what are
you gonna do what the [__] you can do
this was him
this wasn't done by me this was him it's
not me I'm the most innocent most famous
most beautiful person in the entire
world is in the history of ever ever
he goes on to say who he's showing
classified documents to that he's not
supposed to be showing classified
documents to when he knows he's not
supposed to be and the reason why is
that's why he says off the Record and
that's the reason why
he says this all sorts of stuff pages
long look
wait a minute let's see here I just
found isn't this amazing I just I just
found this oh look in my desk drawer
laying on the floor look at what I found
this totally wins my case wins my case
no you just caught a case off this you
[__] idiot
except it is like highly confidential
wait wait what wait go back up Grandpa
you said except it's like highly
confidential secret this is secret
information look look at this
there it is
there's the smoking ketchup fart
right there in his own statements when
he's showing a reporter
classified documents in his words highly
confidential secret this is secret
information
look look at this
I'm not allowed to show this to you this
is illegal what I'm doing by showing it
to you in this way but look look look at
this this is off the Record and here it
is
here it is
your orange smoking fart
if you want to call it that
Donald Trump admitting in his own words
on a recording that it is highly
confidential secret this is secret
information
you [__] idiots out there that are
defending this pile of garbage deserve
everything you're gonna get
what I mean by that is when you go down
the road of delusion and lies
you [__] lose in 2024 my guess is at
this point it's Friday June 9th 12 49 pm
Eastern Time Market Tony Michaels said
that Joe Biden will win by a margin of
15 million votes
against Donald Trump
that's right I said it 15 million votes
will be the margin between Donald Trump
and Biden at a bare minimum
write it down
pulled me to it
it's gonna happen
and here's why
except it was like highly confidential
secret this is secret information look
look at this
and his arguments against what he's
saying
is going to go over like a wet fart and
a white thong just like this right here
as president
I could have
Declassified but now I can't that's why
I'm showing it to you off the Record and
you can't say anything because this is
top secret information that no one's
supposed to look at I wish I would have
Declassified it that way I could show it
to the public because somehow it's
stupidly exonerates me from whatever the
[__] Mark Miller is saying because he's
got some sort of beef with Mark milley
got it
holy [__] [__]
and they're still defending him this
morning and they're going to continue
they're not going to stop
it's not going to happen
they're just not
what a buffoon
this is their guy though this is their
[__] guy like oh
he's so great oh my God he's so [__]
great this is the best thing ever
okay
go with that
someone brings up a good point here on
on YouTube said who did he sell the
secrets to again
I actually believe that this little
recording is a Smoking Gun but it ain't
the only one
it ain't the only one there's all sorts
of reasons why Donald Trump took these
[__] documents all sorts of reasons
why he did
holy [__] we got a good show today
it's oh man
it's it's a good show isn't it Gabe
Sanchez like were you excited when you
woke up this morning or what I mean I I
was I was pretty pumped when I went to
bed because of what I saw and then this
morning it was just like one thing after
another after another after another just
kept piling on
so what do you make is there any
breaking news since I game on because
the last thing I heard is that trusty
and Raleigh were actually um they they
actually resigned they weren't resigned
or they got fired but that that's that's
the that's that's the statement that
they're putting out right well here you
actually want to know you actually want
to know the current narrative that's
happening right now yeah sure they're
trying to say that these that the audio
clips are all AI
oh
they do know they do know that they can
go back to original recordings right
yeah well they don't understand that so
what they think is happening right now
here's here's an example Jason who's
saying this James A lot of people a lot
of people I I've been reading show me
show me a tweet I want to see it I can't
wait here's one tweet that's going
that's going to prove uh Jason Miller
remember who he is he's the guy this is
the thumb that doesn't that is a
deadbeat dad is that the one yeah this
is the guy that wore a mask remember he
wore face mask during the Jan six
hearing depositions that he had uh he
looked like [__] what the [__] this
is great this is great
not AI so there's a so there so the
argument right now is that everything
that you hear or but they're like oh
yeah CNN's got tapes oh everyone hit her
a [__] AI honest to God that is what
they're saying this immediate response
is wait wait AI wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
are you telling me
that manga on the Internet is saying
this image is the reason why Donald
Trump is is innocent this is the main
argument they're making right now which
is oh what about all the documents the
1850 boxes also where did they get that
number well I don't it it definitely in
this picture it definitely looks like
thousands of boxes it looks like
thousands of boxes I mean who can't tell
that that's just thousands of boxes I
mean there's this crazy thing called
science and they're able to compact
paper down into it well Hey listen this
is an AI okay this is an AI all right
this obviously has to be some sort of
like Elon type technology where a
thousand boxes can fit in this photo
yeah well I mean it's kind of like you
ever seen the movie Ant-Man oh yeah
absolutely yeah it's it's that
technology yeah oh that's the technology
you you seem to think that there's not
these particles yeah
you seem to think that Maga pulls all
their theories from fictional movies
it's crazy I gotta tell you I mean like
there's there's no I mean they they
really do an amazing job at creating
Science Fiction it's wonderful are you
kidding you can't even make this [__] up
right yeah you can't make this [__] up
that this is their defense that's a
picture of Joe Biden is their defense of
why Donald Trump isn't guilty let me see
if I can find the CNN stuff but like
basically this is the whole argument
that's trying to make which is the audio
recording that CNN got transcripts for
like oh where's the real audio recording
and I'm like I don't know probably in
[__] evidence right I I what how the
[__] don't they know this and also if
look
this is one of those moments where Jim
trustee and the other lawyer who I don't
even know the name because I've never
heard it until John Roland Raleigh never
heard that name until today honest to
God I've only seen Jim trustee around
I'm sure he's gonna go right back to
doing his legal infomercials on Fox News
and other places but when you get down
to it the thing that no one is disputing
here on their team to be like these
aren't real Clips right this never
happened Trump said I don't remember
that I don't have recollection of that
like the standard thing you don't want
to get you know in trouble for lying
about which is instead of saying that
never happened I was never there I never
said those things I never talked to that
person this is all fake instead he's
like
I I I'm not aware of that Paul I don't
recall there's a reason recall
that he's choosing the as dumb as he is
to talk about the stuff out in public
post about on Truth social he is careful
about some things but at the end of the
day also it just comes down to the fact
that when these accusations or you know
allegations about the fact that he had a
a tape of him talking about this and now
there are transcripts no one is
disputing the fact that these
transcripts exist the only people who
are trying to throw mud at this uh at
this idea that he actually did admit to
taking the documents and did admit to
having classified documents that he
admitted to not declassifying
[Music]
is the fact that like oh it's all AI
have you ever heard of AI deep fake
audio that that could be someone
impersonating him oh my God again again
I understand that that their argument is
mired and absolute lies and delusion but
it's not in a courtroom like you can't
you can't sell the Illusion in a
courtroom they're not gonna let you do
that so so and and what I'm saying is is
that
if it is AI if that's truly what it is
in a courtroom that will play out but
the problem is on the opposite end that
if you're just making [__] up which they
are because Jason Miller Jason Miller
certainly knows if this is a AI or not
he certainly knows that yeah no
questions for sure I'm not making
assumptions I'm telling you Jason Miller
knows rather this is AR iron on he's got
a direct line to Grandpa poopy pants
he's out there defending him all the
time he probably talks to him on the
daily because Jason Miller is one of the
ones that goes out and defends him in
the [__] media and lies for him in
the media and perpetuates his lies in
the media so Jason and Jason Miller
knows that these are lies that's the
whole intent that's why he's in the
[__] in trouble in the first place is
because he continued to ignore the truth
and the truth is that you didn't
declassify these documents you boneheads
and you shouldn't have been showing
whoever the [__] this was when you said
it wasn't off the Record and it's highly
secret it's highly classified it's
highly confidential I shouldn't even be
showing this but look look here look
here look here
you know all that you know all this so
why why why don't you just um
shut your [__] mouths right I mean
that what is it ten words one two three
four five six seven eight nine one one
two three four five six seven eight nine
yeah ten words the ten words that will
most likely be the downfall of trump are
the very words that he uttered from his
mouth as president I could have
Declassified which means you didn't
which means you didn't which means the
whole the whole situation about cash
Patel talking about how you guys are in
the Oval Office and that he was in that
you were declassifying these documents
and that you know what all you got to do
is think about it because here's the
same argument right the same argument we
said about
let's say that Donald Trump pardoned a
bunch of people right but he never told
anyone
and then after the fact something
happens and he goes oh well actually
when I was in office I pardon this
person I'm like okay well do you have it
written down dated you have it like
[__] notarized like what and he's
like oh well no I thought about it I
thought about pardoning this person so
they're pardoned it's like well no that
doesn't work that way you can't do that
and you can't just make up this thing
retroactively to say oh you know what I
was on the [__] at 3am in the morning
rage tweeting and I thought in my mind
uh it would be really good if I uh
pardon that person or I Declassified
those documents none of that [__]
happened none of it happened and the
idea because there's also this argument
too which is like does Trump have a
pocket pardon right could he pull out a
pardon for himself in the eventual like
uh trial of of him being charged for
some crime right but that would assume
that he would have to know the crime
that he was being charged for right now
you could argue maybe Jan six right but
even then the like constitutional law
says that
um you can't pardon something that
you've been impeached for so technically
he couldn't pardon himself for Jan six
but even on the documents he would have
to know what he was partying himself for
he couldn't just do like a Matt Gates
special which is I want to be pardoned
for all crimes from the of all existence
of humanity from when I was born to up
until this point right now right like
there's a reason why all these people
are freaking out
it's because they know they're wrong
they've lost complete control of the
narrative last night I was in a [__]
Twitter space with Mario and seven Sev
gorko and that one guy doc were [__]
losing it
um doc was I thought doc was going to
have an aneurysm Seb Gorka was like I've
got 57 minutes until my next show on
Newsmax and I need you to tell me why I
am wrong about this and it's like oh
they they seem to think that there's
this way the law Works where you can
just like [__] jump over a grand jury
and the president then just streamlines
it over to Merrick Garland and their
Theory right now is that is that Joe
Biden
is politically persecuting Donald Trump
and so he has Jack Smith
and Merrick Garland and a grand jury but
none of those things matter because Joe
Biden is the one who's pulling the
strings again again with this whole idea
that you've got people on the right Seb
Gorka who still believe the election was
stolen right and also the idea that uh
it's all rigged it's all rigged against
him right all these right wing lunatics
are saying that Joe Biden is this
Mastermind but he's also this
incompetent fool right and I do want to
bring up last night I did say because
there were some people that were I think
in the chat that were listening to me
and one of which was Margie he goes he
goes I don't know who this this guy
[__] Chase he goes I don't know who
the Sanchez is and I unmute and I go
love you Seb
so so that was that was a great moment
because I [__] laughed my ass off
when that happened and the reason why is
because he knows who we are he knows who
the [__] we are I've been in there
before never tweeted about him right
never mentioned him in a tweet fucking's
got us but he blocked me you [__]
little [__] said you know who we are
you know why we come at you and you
don't [__] like it because you're a
Pansy you little [__] you think you're
some kind of big man and you're not
you're just not you little man puss now
what the funny part is is he was like
this whoever this is with this last name
Sanchez I was like dude just call him a
Mexican yes do it I mean it was I was
like wow he just called he just called
game of Mexican I'm like Jesus Christ
that's [__] brutal and I don't know
who he is with this last name Sanchez
and then the great part is you
immediately unmute you're like love you
Seb
because all these people you know there
was a moment I I texted you about where
these where they're like oh you can't do
that and then he tried to bring up some
like pro-life Pastor or something and I
cut him off and I was like was he
charged with sexual assault and he was
like oh what that's that's a personal
attack and I was like personal attack on
who yeah and so I was like they're like
well I think or the person they were
talking about it was confusing I think
that he thought it was about him what
the hell does it matter if we're talking
about someone we can eleven eleven
personally he's trying to talk about
something some pro-life person was would
had their house rated right and I like
there are two reasons there are two
reasons why someone's house who's a
pro-life whoever Pastor whatever right
rated one of which is sexual assault I
couldn't get out the second one in time
because he freaked out and was like what
do you do talking about and then you had
Nick sorter who was like whoa what's up
with these what's going on how these
non-sequitur what what's going on I was
like there's a reason why I mentioned it
it's all projection right idea that
Donald Trump and everyone else on the
right are talking about these other
things not to mention that Seb Gorka
brings up somebody's pro-life irrelevant
irrelevant to a document's case about a
former president right you guys want to
bring this up the reason that I
mentioned was he charged with sexual
assault it's because [__] nine times
out of ten if that's ten times out of
ten it's sexual assault or they're
embezzling from their organization or
they got some kind of pictures they're
not supposed to have on their goddamn
laptops or some [__] but they get they
they get all [__] once you rattle
them up they get so agitated especially
when Seb Gorka wants to bring up again
they they are so fixated on 2020 in 2021
and things that happen in those two
years you know especially coven but
during that time Seb Gorka he was like
you know or like yesterday he was
talking about how uh the election was
rigged and this is all political
interference and I said then tell me why
every time they investigate voter fraud
it's always on the right right yeah
you've got people in The Villages you've
got the guy in Pennsylvania who murdered
he's one of the highest concentration
yeah of voter fraud ever is in The
Villages in Florida and none of it was
against Trump all of it was for Trump
and you've got and I was like hey hey I
see the winner that is
they love they love to talk about what
about is and when I'm like you guys play
that game all the time so but I'm not
playing what about is and when I
literally say you made a claim against
Democrats having widespread voter fraud
and rigging the election and I'm
explaining to you that there is no
actual proof of any of these Democrats
especially in widespread numbers to
overturn an election with millions of
Voters and I'm going to show you
examples of Republican
right-leaning people who either are
voted multiple times murdered their
spouse and then voted on their behalf so
please tell me how that's what about ISM
so Nat girl73 on YouTube says I love
hearing about
um these spaces these Twitter spaces
that we're in and what what's what's
great about it is that like
um sometimes it's both of us on stage
sometimes I'm on stage sometimes you're
on stage waiting to speak and a lot of
times me and Gabe are like messaging
text messaging back and forth in the
background like oh this dumb Buck what
an idiot if you get up on stage say this
like we're like we're just in the
background like these dumb [__]
are absolutely scheming in the
background right if someone's up we'll
say yeah definitely make sure to bring
this up for sure and every time we do
they always freak out and they get so
flustered
these these immature people on stage
this I'm gonna go in an interview
whoever this is with the last name same
Chase
he called you a Mexican that's awesome
by the way basically he just he's like
ah who's just Mexican I mean that's
basically what he did that's basically
what he said she is I can't trust that
dirty Mexican if you if you want to if
you want to um listen to us in the
Twitter spaces uh your best bet is to
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michael's
spot
notifications
I think that's how you get notified if
you turn the if you turn the Bell
notification on it'll show in your
timeline that we're in the space right
so and it's it doesn't matter if we're
speaking or just listening I believe if
you have if you have notifications on
Twitter yeah you'll notify that we're
there um and we should um we should
start posting it somewhere when we go in
those spaces like other than Twitter
because you can actually go see those on
Twitter yeah you can listen without
having a Twitter account that's that's
one that's one thing we um you can do so
maybe we should find a way to right I
mean if we learned anything from uh
Tucker Carlson's email to his uh older
generation you don't have to actually
download Twitter and if you get a pop-up
make sure to click the X right
absolutely absolutely so um thank you uh
Nat girl we like going in the spaces and
I'll tell you that what is important
about those spaces I think me and Gabe
talked about this several times I think
we've been talking about it on the show
is that the reason why I go in there is
because the way you have to understand
about those Twitter spaces especially
Marios is all the the Trump operatives
and all the DeSantis operatives are
going in those spaces and trying out
their narratives that's what they're
doing is they're trying them out to see
how they land what what does it sound
like what does this argument sound like
how does that work what what is it what
is it and last night even Matt gatz was
listening to the room at one point yeah
speaking of which Matt Gates yeah he uh
he now has a little probe
who knows if he likes it I don't know I
uh yeah sure but it seems like the
Ethics Committee is uh uh oh you're
looking oh they're looking they're
probing not a hard probe soft Pro oh
okay I don't know what he's into well he
might be into soft he might be in a
heart who knows
um one guy that got probed in this
documents Kate says Walt NADA or NADA
not how did you say his last name not a
like a naughty boy naughty naughty said
but would say he's a naughty boy
um
so he's an aide to the president in the
White House and outside the White House
now Walt here is going to get charged in
this case and indicted in this case on
some of these charges along with Trump
and I would suspect that it's the
conspiracy charges now knowing what I
know about Federal investigations my
guess is is that the reason why they're
charging is because they have evidence
that this guy committed crime and
federal statutes I mean didn't they
reveal this back in 2022 when they
confirmed that he was the aide who Trump
instructed to move the documents well
right but again the evidence is unclear
of that right okay now again you have to
remember and and I want everyone to to
know that the reason why we know
anything about this indictment at all
anything even that it's going to happen
is because of trump
it's all all the leaks all the stuff we
know about it everything is because this
guy can't keep his [__] mouth shut
and Jack Smith is counting on that folks
like he is counting on this guy to
obstruct obstruct obstruct because I I
wouldn't be surprised if we get
superseding indictments with witness
tampering and probably possibly because
of this guy right here he's probably
going to tamper with this witness
because once this guy becomes a
co-conspirator in the case if he flips
on Trump if he cooperates against Trump
in a in a uh effort to get a deal or a
lesser sentence or lesser charges
um and Trump tries to intimidate him and
tamper with his uh what what Walt would
or would not saying like a federal
proffer
um to give the audience an idea I'm not
an attorney but a federal proper is
where you would go in and you would talk
to prosecutors and anything you would
say wouldn't necessarily be used against
you in the court right it can be but not
necessarily
um yeah do you know what's kind of funny
about this yeah you say co-conspirator
but I kind of I kind of have a new
nickname for him he's a diet diet coke
conspirator because is this the guy who
brings him Diet Cokes no no so [__]
way so are you this is the Diet Coke guy
yeah so back in October I mean he's
carrying Trump's tie here you can see
him carrying his ties
The Washington Post reported that a key
witness in this ongoing doj and FBI
investigation of the mishandling
classified documents as a Navy veteran
who followed the former president of
Florida after serving as a valet in the
Trump White House Walt NADA is the
witness in question remember this is
October 14th 2012 22. um
okay according to who spoke on a
condition of anonymity to discuss an
ongoing investigation the 39 year old
worked as a valet for Trump in the Oval
Office Suite according to the former
White House staffers and served as a
personal aide at the Mar-A-Lago Trump
residence private club there was a um it
says it here
uh uh the the one where it says not long
after Trump took office NADA left the
mess to become one of the Trump's valets
spending most of his work day in a small
passageway
that connects the West Wing to a private
dining room from there he had access to
a small refrigerator stocked with Diet
Cokes which he brought to the present in
the Oval Office when Trump pressed a
call button on the desk said a former
White House staffer who spoke on the
condition of amenity to discuss
activities inside the White House the
dude spent time in a [__] passageway
most of the day waiting waiting like a
[__] chimp for someone to press a
button and then him to go do the thing
this is the diet coke button guy you
know we got a lot of new people here on
the show that are watching right now and
a lot of people are saying that they're
uh new to subscribe to the podcast uh
what you should do right now if you're
watching on YouTube is go ahead and
subscribe it's it's free it's free 99 to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
uh join the [__] em fam here in the chat
you can also again follow us on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod we're going to do
bonehead a week here in a minute
um I mean we've been doing bonehead of
the week the whole time and really
honestly I mean play the music and yeah
show you a view gambits it's pretty much
the bone end of the century type thing
uh you can also watch us on Facebook
every single weekday Monday through
Friday at the Tony Michaels if you still
got a Facebook account you can follow us
on Twitch and go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels it's free to follow us on
Twitch but you can also use your Prime
account to tie it to your Twitch account
and give us that one free subscription
we get a few dollars and it doesn't cost
you anything extra extra
oh my God I just wanted to give us a
shout out there you know what if you
want to show support
this is a great day to bring up uh rake
stepping they always step on the rake so
go to store in that D Tony michaels.com
that's
store.thetonymichaels.com and you can
find your let them eat rake merch as
well as the great design by Gabe Sanchez
on the pride welcome logo you can go
check that out store not the Tony
michaels.com and you can also go to the
tonymichaels.com and you can uh check
out all the links there to all the
social media Gabe's uh merch stores
there as well so give us some support we
appreciate every every single bit of it
as always we've got a we got breaking
news we've got breaking news it looks
like yeah what do we got what time is
this going to be at hold on is this is
this going to be a press conference for
mayor Garland it looks like it yeah um
so so I I um I fully expected that we
would have some stuff like this and um
we we can go long we may have to take a
couple breaks here
um to go along but
um we can no longer if we need to you
know what it is 3 P.M Eastern so and
we'll be way too uh wait for that so so
we'll probably we'll be covering that on
Monday and uh more than likely
um we'll be doing extra content for this
so go to patreon.com and search oh yeah
Michael's and I am Gabe Sanchez we'll be
doing something I'm sure this weekend
I'll be doing my rant my weekend ramp
um and it'll be on this subject because
Tuesday is when he gets a rain now this
is very important yeah and I don't want
to talk about this for a bit the reason
why is because next this week everyone's
excited next week everyone's going to be
pissed off and the reason why is because
this guy's gonna get arraigned on all
these Federal counts of that where he
violated the Espionage Act and this
[__] is going to walk free a
reality winner never walked free right
it was always you know right A lot of
these January 6 insurrectionists that
went and tried to overthurn the
government in his name they didn't want
free they stayed locked up like Stuart
Rhodes and Rick atario and the like this
guy's gonna walk free next week expect
that he's going to walk out of the
courthouse yeah because there is a
two-tier justice system in this country
it does exist the only reason why
they're mad about it and they keep
bringing it up is because their tier
doesn't seem to be protecting them
anymore especially Trump yeah I mean
last night they got so pissed off and
they were like gay but don't you think
it's unfair and I go no if a crime is
committed for anyone anyone Democrat
Republican independent whoever they are
people's party they should all be hell
held accountable and and uh and admit to
the crime they've done and if you really
believe if you really believe that this
guy is innocent right because he's
proven guilty he's innocent until proven
guilty right so like if you really
believe that this guy is innocent then
the facts of the case will present
themselves and the jury will decide
how to move forward right but keep in
mind that you had a grand jury that
voted on these on on several different
counts
that he committed right felony counts
right and that was something else Seb
Gorka was like these are civil charges
this is a civil case and it's like no
dude Trump is the one who literally
changed the rules of what the punishment
should be back when he was president
right so the irony and the karmic beauty
of this coming back to hit him in the
[__] face is amazing
he is he is the only problem that he's
in trouble he said those things he did
those things he set up the [__]
punishment for said things
he he's the dumbest criminal
in modern history and the only reason
he's been able to protect himself is
because of you know money or connections
or this two-tier justice system that
they're now complaining about right well
here's the other thing too that they're
not going to be able it's really
um this whole all it's rigged and it's
all against him and it's all Witch Hunt
it's starting to fall apart this morning
because as we found out judge Cannon the
one who was very very very very very the
one who basically lost any sort of
career uh uh credibility credibility
yeah but it looks it looks a lot of
people that have worked within the
Appellate Court down there in the 11th
District
uh believe that this will be overturned
and shouldn't be reassigned but but
the point is is that the system the
system picked her right yeah yeah and
Jack Smith knew that this could happen
he's no [__] dummy here he knew this
could happen and he's still he still did
what he knows he needs to do and bring
this case in the correct jurisdiction
because the last thing he wants is some
sort of [__] fight over change of
venue in it and it it bang up his case
so he took the risk of Canon being
judged now at this point
Canon is the judge now Brian has a a
pretty good tweet on this and I don't
agree with everything that he says here
but these are the facts he says
Americans need to understand the
separation of power now judge cannon at
Trump appointee will oversee the case
for now that's what we have in this
situation Trump was indicted in a red
state which and I don't know if I agree
with him that Florida is exactly a red
state but you know you can argue that
right well that's what they that well
here I mean he's he's just using their
argument well but that's right that's
what I'm saying right I'm saying that I
don't exactly agree with that no yeah
yeah this is but this is the argument
that you need to make when these [__]
chuckleheads these Michael chuckleheads
come in
he goes on to say he's in that red State
a grand jury was impaneled right so the
grand jury that actually indicted him on
these charges not in D.C
it's in Florida yeah and that Florida
grand jury in a trump heavy District
right is
the one who brought these charges or at
least said yes we you should bring these
charges at least 12 of the 15 jurors had
voted to a hand down an indictment
meaning that's the threshold you had to
get 12 of the 15 to vote to get it so
that's that that's what we know we know
that's the bare minimum to bring these
charges a federal judge who has no
connection with the executive branch
oversaw the entire process meaning that
this judge who is in the court system
doesn't take orders from Joe Biden right
that's all [__] that's such a
[__] farce even if even if Jack Smith
takes orders from Merrick Garland who
takes orders from Joe Biden this judge
who oversaw the grand jury process is
why didn't this is why you do grand
juries in the first place is to make
sure to bring as much justice as you can
and I know they say oh you if you if you
want you can indict a ham sandwich well
yeah this is one of the most crooked ham
sandwiches that's ever been in Texas
yeah so I mean the the idea that they
all want to complain about this or or
actually one argument they tried to make
last night which I in in uh Tira and
some other people were like this doesn't
make any sense you guys are [__]
idiots because you're logic about how
this is all an attempt to take down
Trump so that he can't run in the 2024
election right and it's like if you
really were under that belief
right because they were like oh they
tried it with Manhattan D.A and they're
gonna do with this one they're gonna do
it then they're gonna try and take him
down it's like look
if you've noticed you've seen there has
been an opposite reaction right he's
been able to fundraise off of it griffed
off of it his his poll numbers have
performed better from those things
because he's played the victim if this
really was a strategy by the Democratic
party to hold Trump accountable to ruin
his chances to interfere with the
election they're doing a [__] shitty
job of it
the other argument that doesn't make
sense is they keep saying oh it's
political and you know I talked about in
the first 30 minutes yeah you got him
right it's political and we should make
it political I mean they're the
political weaponization of Jim I mean he
also made it political right yeah he's
making political it was it was political
from the point at which he stole the
documents lied about the documents right
kept the documents hid the documents
lied about hiding the doctor I mean he's
talking about in the tapes that in the
recordings these are classified right
and and I'm getting retribution on Mark
milley hereby showing you these he's
like oh check out him check out Iran
like what's right like right you want
political retribution on Mark Billy here
it is I'll show it to you
um so Brian goes on to say here that the
federal judge had to find probable cause
in order to sign off on any subpoena or
warrant
um now again that doesn't mean that it
can't be [__] but it also means that
they're using the same system for Donald
Trump as anyone else so when they say if
they can do it to Trump then they can do
it to you yeah if they can do it to you
they should be able to do it to Trump
they should be able to use the same
process
you should do the time right well the
thing is getting lost here though is
that
um even when Michael Cohen was in the
space last night because he was in the
space too and someone brought up that
individual one was stated on his
indictment which we all know that it was
Trump an individual one was not actually
indicted and the reason why is because
he was a sitting president the reason
why it seems like all these charges and
all these cases are coming against
Donald Trump all at once is because he's
not the president anymore which break
brings to the point of Jim Jordan and
James Comer he can't charge a sitting
president we've been through this yeah
we tried we would love to have done that
with the last [__] but you can't
do it they won't do it they won't do it
because there is a two-tier justice
system and for sure it protects the
sitting president United States sitting
is the key word
um it goes on Brian goes on to say here
the head of the investigation was an
independence special prosecutor chosen
for his lack of bias now rather you
believe it or not
um you know I guess you could but he
goes on to say you can claim that the
prosecutors the judges the jury are all
corrupt but why don't you consider for
just one second the guy being charged
under the espion that Espionage Act may
have actually been the corrupt one well
they can't do that and the reason why
they can't do that is because it
destroys their entire narrative for the
last six years and really the last 15
years yeah we want to know the honest
truth because the reason why Donald
Trump came to to to be the darling of
Maga and and bunch of Toothless rednecks
which I don't understand there's Blue
Collar billionaire [__] number one he's
not blue collar he's not a billionaire
and what would attract anyone from some
[__] New York Elite get the [__] out
of here with that nonsense but here's
the thing here's the thing the way
Donald Trump became the darling of a
bunch of [__] bigots around the
country is he went on Time After Time
After Time again and talked about Barack
Obama's birth certificate that's how how
he [__] did this that's how it
started and boy isn't it funny isn't it
funny that how he started was with the
document and how it seems that it's
going to end is with a bunch of
documents
I mean the idea that Donald Trump
thought that he could get away with this
stuff right and again like this is
coming from the people who scream Law
and Order Law and Order Law and Order
We're the Party of Law and Order you
should do the time if you commit a crime
right you should you should you should
uh
uh you shouldn't hide you shouldn't lie
you should always comply right and it's
like okay well you know if and and
that's the biggest
biggest thing here which is like oh well
what about what about Biden what about
pens yeah well here's the thing the
difference in
you kind of set the stage for the the
very the bare minimum of what was
acceptable
uh the idea that they said oh [__] we
have these documents here you go
we're gonna return them oh sorry don't
know how they got shuffled in here but
here you go we're giving them back you
guys can search the house you can search
the office you can search the property
you can search the business whatever you
guys need to do just go through
however with Donald Trump
we now have learned that he used
maintenance workers to move the
documents
in Mar-A-Lago we have footage that we
have not seen But the grand Juria scene
of them moving said documents around
marlaco there's an audio tape and there
probably are other audio tapes but
there's at least one right now where
Donald Trump is talking about military
documents that were classified that he
knowingly took that were not
Declassified by him and he said oh well
if I was present I could but I can
anymore
and he's shuffling the paper showing
this person
well check out the stuff about Iran oh
check out that check out that oh
whatever it doesn't it doesn't matter
the guy is is going to be the his own
downfall by the things he said on tape
recorded uh giving a direction telling
you know telling aids to tell Evan
Corcoran not to go into that office the
fact that Jim trusty and the other guy
who have already forgotten his name even
though I just learned it this morning
when he told me
these guys resigned but it might also
due to the fact that they literally saw
that the transcripts came out they could
have like you know played Dumb and were
like oh the transcripts we don't know
what is on there right and then the
transcripts became public and they're
like
well we already had a pretty [__]
week case so uh I think this is a good
time I'll tell you I'll tell you I I
actually uh have a theory about why
trustee and this Raleigh I think his
name is
um Boulder resigned and the reason why
is because they don't want to lose their
law license yeah that's they don't want
to lose the ability to practice law and
Donald Trump is probably our has been
pressuring them and probably has
continued and their fear is that they he
will continue to pressure them on
what is acceptable in court alone what
they can and cannot do to try to get
this case in a position where it could
be you know wiped away but it's not it's
not going to be wiped away there's
evidence the grand jury is now
apparently indicted he's going to be
rained on Tuesday this is not going away
it's not just going to disappear that's
not a thing um I do have I do have a
statement from one of the head Nazis
um in the Maga movement Charlie Kirk
says here one day the Democrats will
look back on at this and regret they
ever pushed us this far what the [__]
out of here man dumb as dog [__] what do
you think if that guy can figure out
where his forehead starts and ends then
he can come and talk okay well I mean
this sounds like a guy who's scared he
might get indicted in the January 6th
part of the special counsel because he
was he was [__] paying for people to
be bussed to Washington DC to commit a
violent Insurrection so spare me the
[__] Charlie spare me the [__]
Democrats you want to know mother
another person that is a Nazi I mean he
revealed himself last week when he was
like oh I didn't know this person was a
fascist which is Tim Poole click the
quickly
third link and then we'll go back to the
second one oh okay I mean I guess
actually you know we can start with this
we can start with this one you want to
start with this one okay okay so Tim
Poole is getting really upset at the
fact that there are these AI generated
images of trump
seen making out embracing hugging all
this stuff with who found Chi oh baby he
because he loved fauci he did yeah just
loved him too by the way did you know
that they were both in love with voucher
right is there any AI images of DeSantis
making alafachi I'm sure we could find
some you know what's funny I bet when
Anthony fauci looks at these he [__]
thinks this is hilarious but what
[__] trumpers he's like you guys are
[__] um let's take that clip from uh
from Mean Girls like why are you so
obsessed with me like it's or it's
[__] Mariah Carey like why are you so
obsessed with me it's just this idea
that they can't get these people out of
their heads they're so fixated they have
Tunnel Vision on owning the libs and it
just shows them that they're either
maybe closeted no judgment but like
don't attack other people from that
Community or the fact that they're
projecting their own crimes
you know again and they get upset when
you call it out free here says seriously
guys stop with the AI photos of trump
and bouncey it makes Tim cast very
uncomfortable he was at 45 DeSantis now
he's zero percent DeSantis next he'll be
20 negative 25 to Santa's which means he
won't even be able to vote for his
re-election in 2028. we must not anger
Tim Poole folks don't do it whatever you
do don't spread these around and tag
team in it so so then go to the go to
the third link yeah and this sets it up
because we're gonna watch it we're gonna
watch a little clip that was a DeSantis
ad that was released so this is from
Temple's uh little account right yeah
yeah okay so on this account
there's a video that's that it's shared
from the um oh I see the Santa's worm
yeah so if if we play the video you'll
get context of why he's getting really
[__] upset about this okay so let's
let's listen to the to the video here
why is it you're fired
get fired
okay
should you fired Falcon so a lot of
people ask me that question and I did it
right because if you do fire him you're
going to have a Firestone on the left
again why why did you feel unable to
fire
personally you're not allowed to every
time he goes on television there's
always
um but there's a bigger bomb of your
firearm frankly you can't win that one
if I would have done it I would have
taken he
so go back okay so this is from the
DeSantis words so scroll back to like
through right there okay okay right
there okay if you notice these two
images okay it's three images top left
right this one here middle bottom right
here and bottom right this here these
are the a these are all AI generated
images that's great so these are images
that you know what's funny about this
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait stop
stop stop their whole argument this
morning is like oh this is AI this is AI
and like the reason why they're saying
that is because they clearly want to use
AI to spread lies around
are you are you people seeing the
[__] projection here it's [__]
dude it's Insanity so so these are the
three images that are in question right
so then you go back to Tim Poole's tweet
well here's the DeSantis War Room here's
what they say yeah yeah Trump became a
household named by firing countless
people on television
but when it came to fauci and then there
was the video so here's here's Tim
Poole's response to their little their
little video holy [__] this is dirty as
[__] why is it dirty because they're
using AI wait I thought I thought the
right doesn't use it I thought it was
the lead wait wait wait wait wait
I mean
we're gonna piss them off you're gonna
piss him off listen this morning we're
supposed to believe that it's only the
left it's only the Democrats that are
using AI to to set people up and make
sure that we use AI for politics but
here Tim Poole is seeming to think that
it's a bunch of fascists Rhonda Santa
supporters dude there's no bigger
[__] Nazis and and fascists listen if
you love Donald Trump you're [__]
weird it's delusional yeah it's it's
it's [__] dumb at best but if you're
a Rhonda santis fan you are a [__]
Nazi I mean cold-blooded
[Music]
so Temple goes on to say the Santa's
worm is running AI images of trump
embracing bouncy this crosses the line
[__] out of here man crosses the line I
could guarantee I could guarantee
that if this if Trump ran the same ad
right people will be like oh as long as
soon yeah oh it's so funny that he used
Ai and then haha it's so funny he
totally he totally burned a scientist
with a clearly it's AI Gabe yeah and no
one would ever believe that it's not a
so it's it's okay it's okay that Trump
does it it's okay to Trump does because
I because I love Trump and I like to
lick his balls and stuff they taste so
they taste so good they taste like
classified documents and ketchup get the
[__] out of here Tim you are a [__]
weak feeble little piece of [__] man
grow some [__] balls and grow some
goddamn hair stop covering it look I
wear a hat but I got [__] hair you
little [__] go get gender reconfirming
surgery and get you some [__] hair
plugs you little
anyways here's the guy that has a
[__] sword and a musket gun on this
on his wall like Oh I'm a little tough
guy and he's like on January 6th uh
people are gonna be going to the camp at
all
what an idiot uh and of course then he
he does a screenshot of an article yeah
so he has oh and these are AI generated
images
so so what so what get over it someone
in the community notes is gonna say
something and they already did look it
says it right there on the community
notes that their AI generated let's get
over it you Jesus Christ you whiny
little [__]
politics you know why they're whining
about it being politics do you want to
know why why you really want to because
they're gonna lose on the politics oh
yeah that's that's why that's that's why
they're pissed off about that right
politics is they're gonna lose that
battle they're gonna lose that war they
know it they and they they love Trump
they want him to be the leader they want
to be the dictator and King but they
know they're going to lose because he's
a [__] loser that's why they're like
oh it's all politics so they'll get us
in a political match let's do it let's
do it I mean if you guys really want to
want to [__] argue the Merit of the
law then let's follow it to a t right
the very one that Donald tret Donald
Trump set up in terms
for punishment for taking these
classified documents right again it's
just a sweet it's like a mix of like
irony and Karma I just noticed this free
guy that you sent me yeah yeah I guess I
didn't go to his profile I told him
thank you for the Tweet which I really
do thank you for this journey but his
profile says Christian conservative
husband father independent former
Republican it sounds like I'm assuming
he's a DeSantis uh former Republican oh
he said it says former and that Former
Republic okay I don't know I mean well
who knows maybe I would have to I would
have to I still thank him for his tweet
because those wedges even if even if
you're a Santa supporter those are the
wedges we need folks those are the
wedges we need we need to draw them
speaking of that let's go to a quick
break when we come back
go to Bonet of the century I guess this
is gonna be a not a tough one or a tough
one maybe I don't know man this one was
pretty close
people people will see that this race
was very very close but there is one
thing that I want to talk about when we
come back before we start the bonehead
and it's Crackle Barrel because
apparently they're boycotting Cracker
Barrel I don't mean to step on the whole
news but this may be related so don't go
anywhere and pay attention to boycotts
in the next break this has been
everyone's favorite commercial
since we brought this back so pay
attention we'll be right back with more
bonehead of the century and Cracker
Barrel something we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
what are you gonna put in your boycott
binder I wish those things are real
maybe they should make them I don't know
along with the pardon Blended oh man I
want to tell you guys thank you
everyone's going to the uh bird stores
buying up all the
Pride [__] merch and let them meet
rake merch really do appreciate it
bonehead of the week
I'm not even gonna do this for you I'm
just going to do this one because it's
just it's just a [__] bone-in I don't
know I'm able to do this yeah yeah
that's good let's do a normal burning I
don't know it doesn't feel like bonehead
as much because it's just it's like one
of them so let's look at our contestants
here
oh I'm just gonna talk about Crackle
Barrel first
yeah I gotta go back all right go back
let's talk about Crackle Barrel first
okay we'll do this they're hella woke up
here yeah well here is um let's see if
we can remove that for a second
the Texas family project who are these I
don't know who the [__] Texas now I saw
a screenshot that got really upset
down by the mob I'm going to their
straight [__] tweet man this Texas
family project I'm gonna go straight
after him you know me I don't take
screenshots I go right after these
[__] all right it says Texas
family project here which sounds like a
bunch of fascists trying to you know
Christian up their whole their whole
movement okay it says um
here's the here's here's the actual um
media from Cracker Barrel I guess
um this this what it looks like now
they're mad obviously about the The
Pride part of it so Cracker Barrel lgbtq
Alliance so they're really mad that gay
people go and eat Cracker Barrel is that
what they're mad about yeah well I guess
uh I guess so it says uh bringing the
front porch to Pride okay have you ever
been to a Cracker Barrel have you ever
been yeah yeah yeah but they're
typically only the places when I would
stop like as I'm on a road trip like a
road trip because they're like on
Interstate yeah okay so a Cracker Barrel
like and they should call it Cracker
Barrel
if you want to know the answers but but
it looks like a big old [__] Country
Store right yeah you walk into the gift
shop you know right well yeah when you
walk in it's a retail store like the
restaurants in the back right where they
serve the biscuits and gravy and the
eggs and the soup and you know whatever
I'm not a big fan of Cracker Barrel in
terms of food really I mean listen I I
I'm I I've ate a Cracker Barrel several
times it's all right it's good food it's
you know I mean it's not like worth the
hype yeah Cracker Barrel but some people
really like it and and most people like
if they have a certain thing they like
on the menu that's why they're going in
the versions well when you go to Cracker
Barrel because they're on an interstate
a lot of times like a tour bus or poo in
or some [__] so they got they got a big
huge covered front porch on every single
one they all look the [__] same yeah
yeah if you've been in one Cracker
Barrel you've been in all those
[__] right it's like if you've
ever met Mike Pence right you've met all
the saltine crackers from Indiana same
thing yeah yeah you know one Cracker
Barrel you mean all the Cracker Barrels
but on the front porch because a lot of
times there's a wall a long wait they
have all these rocking chairs right they
got them lined up and you can buy them
and a lot of States like there there'll
be black ones there'll be white ones
they'll be they'll be like like wherever
you're at like if you're for instance
like Columbia Missouri that already
sounds pretty well dude the fact they've
got different colored chairs I know I
know I know I know but when you go to
Columbia Missouri there's one in
Columbia Missouri on Interstate 70.
that's the closest one to me I believe
and um they'll have like mu because
Columbia Missouri is the Missouri
University so I had like the team the
team themed chairs right if you go to
like Kansas City they'll have Chiefs
chairs and Royals chairs right rocking
chairs so you can buy these things they
got like brain Stags on them and [__] so
that's what they mean by the front porch
is because you literally go to Cracker
Barrel and sometimes you sit on the
front porch of the Cracker Barrel
waiting to get seated but it says bring
the front boards to Pride this year's
Cracker Barrel's Focus was to be be part
of the pride experience oh my God this
sounds like the end of a Nation to be
quite honest with you this is kind of
Doom and Gloom here Gabe it says we have
two locations in the park both equipped
with seating areas and covered for
people to sit down and cool off what the
[__] what the hell they want people to
sit out and go up in the park while they
beat lgbtq is that what they're saying
wow wow Tony I got sorry man I got
breaking news right now well yeah I was
trying it looks like yeah the indictment
has been unsealed oh okay in Miami
Federal Court wow so they're why are
they jumping ahead you think
Donald and Associate Walt NADA have been
unsealed okay hang on let me let me pull
this up we'll go back to the we'll go
back to the Cracker Barrel
um
uh boycott thing real um we'll go back
to that okay so here is uh Hugo
um he says breaking indictments to
Donald Trump and Associate Walt have
been unsealed do we have do we have them
yet can you find them I'm looking I
don't think we have them yet but uh
they've been sealed so I'm sure that
they'll be Hugo will be releasing them
momentarily right well um maybe let's
check uh let's check Scott and see if
Scott has him he may have them as well
um let me see well you know what Kyle
Chaney probably has him before Scott
will uh let's go to Kyle Cheney's page
Kyle Cheney uh follows the federal oh
and it's Friday I totally forgot oh my
God George Santos holy [__] what what
what what's what's going on with George
today was this okay here here it is yeah
um uh breaking read the 49-page
indictment against Trump here's Kyle
Chaney I told you Kyle would have it uh
Kyle has it here and it's he just
tweeted it like two minutes ago maybe
not even two minutes ago oh boy and it's
politico.com
I gotta get it in a window here
um there it is okay so I'll read up on
the store Santa's one because this is a
breaking news so what's what's the
George Santos thing so George Santos if
you remember the timeline it was
supposed to be the unsealing of this is
supposed to be the unsealing of the
names
so George Santos at 10 35 a.m uh which
appears to be eastern time uh yeah uh
filed appeals to keep names of those who
helped 500 000 pounds sealed now
remember the judge at the time on two
Monday or Tuesday uh Monday uh said that
there was no reason right he filed an
eight-page appeal which I haven't read
yet submitting the filing just before
the noon deadline
Sanders argued that the people who
helped helped him post a bond would
likely have to withdraw from serving as
his bond supporters if their names are
released
ooh that's interesting this Santo says
could have forced him into pre-trial
detention or impose him upon onerous
summer conditions some are saying that
um
it's sealed because
what what's going on here
some people are saying that it's he
appealed so it's going to be stay sealed
that's not that's not what's happening
so on okay so I'm sorry I'm reading Yeah
Yeah so basically what happened was on
Friday they were supposed to file right
he filed for an extension boom went to
Monday Monday they had a 5 PM uh filing
deadline he filed and the judge was like
well I don't see a reason why you would
need to do this and then
um
and then then you then you get to a
point where the judge says that and I'll
give you until Friday at noon
to appeal this but I don't see him
winning this there's no reason the judge
even said so that it wouldn't doesn't
make any sense why you would need to
well let's go to the Donald Trump
indictment here since it's the breaking
news
um because you'll see here on this
indictment um it has Donald Trump and
his co-conspirator here Walt teen his
name is not Walt it's Walt teen by the
way oh like Saltine Jesus [__] Christ
are you kidding me Walt teen NADA okay
so
um indictment the grand jury charges
that uh General allegations at times
material to this indictment on or about
the dates of approximate times below
okay so here's the introduction
defendant Donald J Trump was the 45th
president of the United States why
didn't they say the greatest president
of all time received the most votes of
any sitting president anywhere [__] and
here we go he held office from January
20th uh no no no no no that's fine dude
you should go to the tweets he's he oh
man this is uh okay what's the Tweet
send me the tweets it's uh it's on to
the chain in the thread that he started
who um go back to my tweets yeah uh hang
on let me let me guess he's gonna pull
out the parts that and one of these
parts says in August of September in
August or September 2021 Trump showed a
representative of his pack who did not
possess a security clearance a
classified map related part you're
talking about in here uh yeah it was
like a minute ago no no no that's the
next part that's a part about but we can
read that part first okay let's do this
first so this is number two over the
course of his presidency Trump gathered
newspapers press clippings letters notes
blah blah blah and other materials and
cardboard boxes that he would keep at
the White House so in other words
they're alleging that he would he was
keeping these things
um to take with him among the materials
Trump stored in the boxes were huntered
a classified documents so he was
collecting this stuff as he was going to
take with him the classified documents
Trump stored in the boxes including
information regarding defense and
weapons capabilities of both the United
States and foreign governments United
States nuclear programs potential
vulnerabilities the United States and
its allies Jesus Christ to military
attacks oh my [__] god the plans for
possible retaliation response to a
foreign attack an unauthorized
disclosure of these classified documents
could be put at risk National Security
United States foreign relations and the
safety of the United States military the
human sort and human sources that
continue uh a viability of the
sensitivity intelligence collection
methods Jesus Christ AKA spies yes so so
this guy so basically what they're
alleging here in the indictment in this
first part is that Trump was
intentionally putting these documents to
decide a potential vulnerabilities of
the United States
are you are you listening out there you
[__] manga idiots
he's a he's a treasonous piece of
[__] [__] you [__] he's
collecting up information that he could
I don't know I don't know maybe maybe he
could give to someone that that way
they'd give his Fame like two billion
dollars for the vulnerability of the
United States you [__] scumbags
defending this pile of [__] you piece is
a [__] trash okay this next one is
this the um the August or September yeah
okay so um here here this is um another
subject of the indictment it says in
August or September of 2021 and they
must not know the exact time yeah uh
this at the BET Minster Club oh [__]
Trump showed a representative his
political action committee who did not
possess a security clearance a
classified map related to
a military operation and totally
representative that he should not be
showing it to the representative and
that the representative should not get
too close is this the guy that went and
testified
before the Miami grand jury the other
day because that guy is a representative
of the political action committee right
everyone wrong about that yep yep what
was that motherfucker's name what the
[__] was his name there's so many
[__] treasonous piece of [__] in this
timeline this story of
absolute absolute derangement
uh
I mean I'm just I'm just [__]
snowballing here but that's what this
says
showed a representative as political
action committee
former Trump let's see if this is the
guy because that because that was the
guy and Taylor budowich right yeah and I
think is that the guy that isn't that
the guy that tweeted was like this is
not at all what this is about yes yeah
yes you [__] idiot dude oh man okay
um let's see if we've got any more from
this okay so um Trump uh Kyle goes on to
tweet here Trump retain classified
documents uh from these agencies from
leaving office doj says I want to show
you this Kyle is like an expert right
yeah but he's typing and reading so fast
he misspelled from
I'm just I'm pointing it out because
this guy's reading in real time and he's
trying to get this out as fast as he can
because this is huge news
um let's read this part of the um the
indictment here that he's pointing out
or at least take a look at it um so
these are the agencies that that he's
alleging so the CIA
DOD the National Security Agency
um Jesus Christ in ngia the National
Jesus Department of energy
yeah Department of State the Bureau of
intelligence and research oh you got to
be [__] kidding me man
what the [__] this guy's in so much
[__] trouble
this is after leaving office this is
what this is what Nara he took the
documents
Jesus [__] held the documents lied
about having the documents told him that
he gave the documents back lied about
giving the documents back lied about
where he re replaced and put the
documents
right these are all things that you if
you're innocent okay look let's just get
this out of the way right if you're
innocent and you take documents right at
the very beginning he could like oh [__]
my bad
I didn't mean to do that it got shuffled
in here you go here are the documents
here's everything that you guys should
have back I shouldn't have taken it
again apologies my mistake
that's what Joe Biden did that's what
Mike Pence did that's what anyone else
who had to search for documents say oh
[__] did you have old documents that got
put into a box and brought to a home or
whatever
anyone in that situation was like oh
yeah I should take responsibility and
own up to the fact that we accidentally
took documents that I should have had in
the first place and then Donald Trump is
like I didn't have the documents what
documents starting you guys plan the
documents okay fine I took the documents
but I Declassified the documents and you
guys are trying to say that I couldn't
have the documents but they're my
documents because I had those documents
while I was present and I Declassified
those documents and I waved him over
with my magic hands and I thought with
my big old brain tiny tiny Magic Hands
yeah sorry tiny tiny don't oh sorry
tiny Magic Hands I Declassified the
documents and I
I had an aneurysm and I Declassified
them okay
and cash Patel was there he was there
too cash Patel will even tell you that
he was in the Oval Office with me when
he um
December what happened okay Kyle Chaney
in December of 2021 Walt Mata who is who
is his co-conspirator on this case found
some of Trump's boxes had toppled and
Spilled onto the floor where he saw
documents designated as five eyes
intelligence NADA took pictures of the
spill
these are pictures that Walt NADA took
are you [__] [__] me
oh my God I cannot wait for Marios I
cannot wait for Mario Spaceman today
oh my God can you message him and make
sure we're both in that [__]
yeah oh my God this what the [__] these
[__] idiots are you [__] me
listen here's the thing is they did the
problem is is that they can't pull out
okay they're already too deep in they
cannot pull out of trump this is gonna
be you you [__] to try to have this baby
this is gonna be [__] life baby I
can't wait to see them [__] sidestep
around the the evidence
just alone in this indictment they're
not I and I I haven't read the rest of
it
I'm reading it as we go along here
I'm a good God are you [__] me
I I can't I this is not surprising in
the least that that he would say because
wasn't it wasn't wasn't it Trump that
said oh they they planted they made it
look like it was spilled on the floor or
whatever you know that's been one of
their things the whole time is the
picture he was like they did it they put
they they put their things in the open
box this is hilarious and the reason why
you know that he was [__] lying then
is because he's projecting they had
evidence that they were spilling them
out on the floor and they were taking
[__] pictures of them spill out on
the floor
oh man you
know you okay let's see let's see if
there's anything else going on here of
course there are several pictures
now they're blacked in they're black and
white on this indictment
um and it looks like what do you call it
when you do the um when you edit the
picture to look like to look like that
when you make them well no when you make
them look like when you make them look
like this
it's not redacted invert I don't know
they it looks like it's inverted right
well because they're not showing them
it's just it's just like a
right well but I don't know I mean I
guess I guess it would be they redacted
that stuff I guess I I don't know what
you call this but it's clearly not a
colored uh image and they have the well
it's happy the reason that it's not
color is the same way like if you ever
were to file your insurance claim and
you have to submit photos to be like I
actually own these items the way that
their software process it's not in color
it's in black and white and I know that
for a fact because uh
because I've gone through that and I've
had to submit stuff and they're like oh
we can't tell what item you're talking
about because we don't have color
um and how the the software uh process
so it just it's just it's just it's just
the things are put into high contrast I
want to show you this is directly from
the indictment I'm looking at the
indictment right now and here's these
pictures
um this is this looks like
um boxes were stored in mar-a-lago's
club white and gold ballrooms so this is
inside the ballroom obviously this is
like a stage here but it's hard to tell
because it's almost like a cartoon
drawing of the actual photo if that
makes right I just messaged uh I just by
the way I just messaged Mario uh and he
was like he's about to start this
Twitter space
baby yes okay well make sure make sure
make sure we're in on it and um tell
them we're on our show right now talking
about his Twitter space make sure he
knows that
um
oh my God this is okay so here here is
um here's another picture now this is uh
where is this at it says after the text
exchange between Trump employee one and
Trump oh my God Trump employee two in
April 2021 some of Trump's boxes were
moved from the business center to a
bathroom and shower in the mar-a-lago's
club Lake room uh as depicted in the
photograph below so not only not only do
they have evidence of employees moving
boxes they have text messages folks
and here's here's the image that they're
using in the indictment of it being
stored in a bathroom so they're moving
them from ballrooms to bathrooms
this is I Jesus
um it's it goes on to say in May 2021
Trump redirected that a storage room on
the ground floor of the Mar-A-Lago club
the quote storage room uh be cleaned out
so that it could be used to store his
boxes didn't this remind you like a
[__] hoarder though right oh yeah you
ever seen that [__] [__] is this the
room is this the room that they were
like hey seal this off and lock it no
one can come in well that that may be
what the storage room is well the
hallway leading to the storage room and
I think that's it because the hallway
could be uh reached from multiple
outside entrances including one
accessible from the Mar-A-Lago club Pool
Patio I think that's this is the one
they're a doorway that is often kept
open the store room was near a liquor
sorry did you say that the room was left
open the doorway the patio so the the
doorway that goes to the from the pool
patio to the hallway yeah okay which
um is often kept open now not unlocked
they're saying open
and that could mean unlocked but to me
it means like they propping it open the
storage room was near a liquor Supply
Closet that makes sense a linen room
Lock Shop
oh [__] and various other rooms
um on June 24th 2021 Trump's boxes that
were in the lake room were moved they
know the dates you know what that means
they have material evidence of the dates
folks
so they got probably got security
footage or text message of people moving
this [__]
yeah after the move they were more than
80 boxes in the store room as depicted
to the photographs below so here's
here's a the photographs that they have
in the indictment
again this is the now they have they
probably have colored very detailed
photographs but these are just the
photographs that they're putting in the
indictment as they're yeah yeah proof of
evidence
um I just want to point out I
I just want to point out that this [__]
is now out there right Jack Smith and
his team ain't [__] around okay they
were able to start this investigation
months ago right
and
are now at the well I mean Donald
Trump's at the find out stage right he's
beginning to end he's like walk through
the [__] door of the find out stage
and now they're like oh you know you can
claim because here's the thing
Donald Trump could say I never did that
I was never there I never talked to this
person this is all fake news
and Jack Smith and whoever you know was
we're like all right let's unseal this
[__] right
like totally [__]
it's like the Mar-A-Lago pool flooded
and it drowned out all of their
arguments and all of their narrative
because what you have here is evidence
you have the unsealed indictment with
photos time stamps text messages and
also the fact that there's employees and
other people hang on I'm just talking
more of course what pages is on well
hang on Kyle's pulling this out let me
um
this is number 54 that Kyle has here
um that he's page 54 no no no number 54.
I'm not sure which page
um Let me let me show you oh let me see
there we go okay uh Kyle says when
Trump's lawyers told him they needed to
search his property for documents he
wondered several times if it might be
better if they just told doj they didn't
find anything oh my god dude and the
attorneys are the ones who testified
this if you remember number 54 on May 23
2022 Trump met with Trump attorney won
and Trump attorney too no [__] way
they're co-conspirators that's why they
resigned this morning I know yep that's
why they resigned this morning they're
Coke and Spears at the Mar-A-Lago Cub to
discuss the response to the May 11
subpoena I wonder if these attorneys
have uh immunity now if they if they
negotiated immunity Trump attorney
wanted Trump attorney too
[Music]
I told Trump that they needed to search
for documents that would be
um would be responsive to The subpoena
and provide a clarification that there
had been compliance with the subpoena
Trump in sub sum and substance made the
following statements among others
as memorialized by Trump attorney won
oh my God I you gotta know that these
attorneys were [__] wearing wires
would you go anywhere near Donald Trump
without [__] wearing a wire nope nope
I would always cry the way the way you
navigate Trump's world is you record
everything you cannot go in empty-handed
you have to have a video a tape a
[__] transcription of some sort there
is no way you ever go in as an employee
of Donald Trump or work with him in some
fashion without having something to
[__] save your ass because God forbid
Donald Trump throws you under the
[__] bus he is you better be ready he
is absolutely [__] here listen to this
hey I don't want anybody looking I don't
want anybody looking through my boxes I
really don't I don't want you looking
through my boxes
well what if we what happens if we just
don't respond at all or don't play ball
with him now I want you to look at the
language here
on a listen to the language on a listen
to me when I say it I don't want anyone
looking I don't want anyone looking
through my boxes I really don't I don't
want them looking through my boxes let
me tell you something this is a
transcription
this is a transcription of trump saying
this out loud in real time that Trump
attorney one trusty more than likely
recorded this
okay let's go to C wouldn't it be better
if we just told them we don't have
anything there oh my God or here Jesus
Christ
well look isn't it better
if there are no documents holy [__] this
guy knows knows he's in big trouble
[Music]
oh my God okay
um let's go on to the next tweet listen
I I just want to know
because they're not going to do it
they're not going to abandon him here
that's the saddest part no I'm curious
I'm curious to hear the [__]
narrative man this is so sad
so beautiful so [__] sad should we go
to the Twitter is he yeah is he open at
Twitter space should we listen in a
little bit while we're doing this I mean
um well I I can on yeah I can get it on
the desktop if if they're open and see
what yeah okay so let me let me go to
this one last part that Kyle has and
then we'll go we'll see what the
chuckleheads are saying
um because folks that's why do those
trumps are those uh Mario spaces on
Trump is because you know exactly what
their arguments are going to be remember
when I said um about the Eugene Carol
thing I said they were gonna they were
gonna bring up Reed Hoffman you remember
that like I called it like Trump is like
you know who he is the one that paid
legal fees and Alina havo was the next
[__] day on Fox News saying uh Reed
Hoffman's name and I told you I told you
on air that last night I listened to
that space and I know that Reed Hoffman
is going to be in their [__] lips
about EG and Carol and by God I was
right and the reason why is because
they're using those spaces folks they're
using those spaces as a way to to
[__] try out their narrative okay
here's Kyle um one more time then we'll
go to the Twitter space and we'll come
back we may have to take I may have take
a piss right here no I don't know I just
got the invite to go speak did you
really okay well um if you want if you
want if you want to go speak in there
for a minute
um tell them we might be covering it
live on on our show
um I'll talk about this and then maybe
we'll we'll kind of switch back and
forth because I am gonna have to take a
break but I don't want to leave yet do
you got time today you got yeah let's do
it let's do an extra hour today now this
is supposed to be Bona of the week folks
but it's bone end of the century to be
quite honest with you so if I mute
myself it's because I'm going on the
call yeah that's fine
um so here is here is um here's Cheney
it says Trump repeatedly had not up
moved boxes in and out of storage room
at his home after being told doj was
coming to retrieve remaining classified
documents so this is this is what uh is
probably the reason why Walt NADA
because he's part of this conspiracy to
shuffle around these boxes and what
that's going to do is going to that's
going to
um allow
Trump to not only subvert the doj but
his own attorneys from this indictment
so let's read from the indictment here
it says um between Trump's May 23rd
meeting with Trump attorney one which we
just read about in Trump attorney too to
discuss the May alignment subpoena and
and June 2nd
when Trump attorney won returned to
Mar-A-Lago club to review the boxes in
the storage room not a removed at
Trump's Direction a total of
approximately 64 boxes
um from the storage room and brought
them to Trump's residence so that's
where
um maybe that his private office or
maybe melania's underwear drawer I'm not
really sure uh exactly where they went
to at that point but here's um here's
more uh in the indictment about uh not a
moving if I can get this thing here
and now I'm moving these boxes
um May 30th 2022 at what Jesus Christ 12
30.
3 P.M
a trump family member
text not a
here we go
text not this is a text message with a
time stamp folks good afternoon Walt
happy Memorial Day woohoo yay I saw you
put boxes in POTUS room
just FYI and I will tell him as well not
sure how many he wants to take on Friday
on the plane oh my god do you remember
the [__] plane video where they're
packing boxes hmm we will not have a
room for we will not have a room for
them notice the knot is capitalized here
okay
plane will be full with luggage thank
you not a reply to this text message
good afternoon ma'am smiley face emoji
oh my God why is that so funny that
smiley face emoji made it into the
Federal indictment against Donald Trump
why am I so excited
side Emoji made it on to the indictment
of Donald Trump you couldn't get more
poetic than that oh he says thank you so
much I think he wanted to pick from them
he wanted to pick from them I don't
imagine him wanting to take the boxes he
wants to select documents to take to
betminster on the plane folks that's
what that's what this is saying he told
me to put them in a room
and then he was going to talk to you
about them talk to you about them he was
going to talk to you whoever you is the
Trump family member who do you think it
is are we gonna play Trump family member
roulette here I don't know oh my [__]
god
folks if you're not aware
um this is this is
some of the biggest the biggest [__]
news
that you will ever see um uh someone's
ivana's grave was it Memorial there was
there for a funeral I don't know I don't
know the date of her funeral Gabe can
you look up
um what the date of her funeral was can
you look up what the date of her funeral
was oh he's gonna get on this space I
think uh
big stuff on uh twitch says yes dig her
up dig her up look if you guys want some
Digger up merch I swear to you I have
dig her up merch we got lock him up
merch as well but we've got Digger up
merch
on stored at the Tony michaels.com I'm
not kidding you if you want to get your
Digger up merch
um just go to store.donymichaels.com
oh man this is insanity okay
um let's see
let's see if we can get uh down to some
more Nitty Gritty here no that's the
same thing okay so
um it looks like uh 7 20 22 was the
burial so when
ah
okay so so this was before this was
before the barrel May 30th was the text
messages and the burial was 7 20. I'm
just trying to put these dates together
um
and on June 1st
Jesus Christ
um they even give a time stamp here so
clearly
here's the time stamp here on June 1st
2022 beginning at 12 52 P.M
NADA removed approximately 11 boxes from
the storage room so they have material
evidence with that time stamp on it okay
that's what that means in this
indictment
um it says on June 1st 2022 Trump spoke
with Trump attorney won by phone they
have record oh my [__] god and ask
whether Trump attorney one was coming to
Mar-A-Lago club the next day for the
exact for exactly what purpose listen
listen there's probably I would imagine
Trump's attorneys were recording him the
entire time every single time they
talked they were probably recording him
um that it seems to indicate that
there's material evidence of this phone
call Trump attorney one reminded Trump
that Trump attorney one was going to
review the boxes that had been
transported from the White House
and the REM and and remained in the
storage at Mar-A-Lago so that Trump
attorney one could have custody of
Records certified that the May 1st
subpoena had been complying with fully
oh my God so I don't know if you're
watching The Tick Tock here but on June
1st Trump spoke with his attorney okay
attorney won and 30 said Yeah we're
definitely coming to the um tomorrow
Lago to check on these documents and and
sometime that day at 12 52 PM Walt NADA
who is also indicted in this in this
conspiracy as a co-conspirator removed
11 boxes from the storage room that the
attorney told Trump they would be coming
to look at
confirming it holy [__] so let's do this
um let me see if I can get to the um
Twitter space here Jesus [__] Christ
this is all insane let's see what these
chocolates are saying about it I'm
really interested to see what um
these morons are saying about it
um I know it's it doesn't seem like
that's what we would want to do but I'm
telling you
um
these boneheads they're they're trying
to start narratives let's see if we can
join it here because Biden
to this time did not show them to other
people he did not discuss them with
people who didn't have security
clearances and again the the the the
point we have to remember with these
charges is you have to prove intent you
have to prove that they intentionally
withheld classified documents and there
is that I mean in the indictment they
talk about how Donald Trump himself can
you guys hear authorize the withholding
of the classified documents he himself
into the White House before they left
knowing that they were classified even
there's even allegations that he
authorized the destruction of some
classified documents we learned that the
room with uh that contained the server
video footage was flooded at Mar-A-Lago
suspiciously guys this is a big deal and
I really want to hear from the
Republicans the trumpies up here because
I don't know how you can defend this so
thank you Mark for having me up I
appreciate it let me go to let me go to
uh Harry just a follow-up question to
your reporting so basically what what
your
um what you said about Biden so you
don't think that any of these counts
that are related to withholding
um classified information we know from
CNN other sources that the documents
found
that were mishandled by then Vice
President Biden did contain top secret
information we obviously don't know
um exactly the contents of that but to
say that that one can be charged and the
other cannot explain how that wouldn't
paint a picture to the American people
absolutely yeah we have a biased giant
uh absolutely justice system 100 so as I
mentioned in my little ranch just there
you have to prove intent that's why the
statute that Donald Trump is being
charged with is willful retention of
classified material willful you have to
prove that they willfully did it that
they know and we did it that they
intentionally did it as of now there's
no evidence that Biden intentionally
withheld classified documents and that's
why we just saw Mike Pence the other day
who he himself had classified documents
on his premise he was exonerated because
there's no intent
with Donald Trump there's intent with
Biden there's no intent and again I want
to make it clear that the Department of
Justice should hold the same standard if
they found intent with Mike Pence indict
him if they find intent with President
Biden indict him but that's the
difference and that's what people have
to understand it's not just like oh you
took a class by document and they found
it in your house there has to be intent
and that's why it's
um so that's Harry's eston
um giving
his view his view of that um and they're
they're trying to tick tock through this
now we're going to bring some there's
gonna be some right Wingers that are
going to come up and they're going to
say a bunch of [__] but again you have
to remember this goes to intent
um holy [__] there's 38 felony counts
good god
um so there's seven charges and there's
obviously several counts of each one of
these charges you're talking about
hundreds of years in prison maximum
God
holy [__] there's material evidence
text messages phone calls recordings
from his attorneys even oh he's [__]
and you're wondering why Trump attorney
won and Trump attorney too
do you wonder why they resigned this
morning I wonder if it's I wonder if
it's because Trump found out this
morning that he gave them material
evidence of his crimes I wonder if that
has anything to do with it it couldn't
be couldn't possibly be that could it
um okay so
um
let's go let's go back to this and let's
see if we can listen in because there's
going to be some right winger stalking
here he thinks he learned something new
but he doesn't realize that the soul
Authority rests with the president
there's also a declassification memo
yeah except Trump admitted on tape that
he didn't declassify them we just
learned that this morning from CNN they
received the official transcript of
Donald Trump himself saying yeah I could
have Declassified this but I didn't so
yes of course he had the sole Authority
but he himself is on tape admitting that
he didn't do that that's why this is so
bad this is why this guy is screwed
and not only that but on page 21 section
54 Trump even admits between attorney
one and attorney two I don't want
anybody looking I don't want anybody
looking through my boxes I really don't
I don't want you looking through my
boxes Part B well what if what if what
happens if we just respond or don't
respond at all or don't play ball with
them part C wouldn't it be better if we
just told them we
we don't have anything here Part D well
what are these communications right the
attorney client these are between that's
why attorney decline privilege exists I
got a phone call I got cut out Hillary
Clinton
president
and when she got us hilarious
this argument could be applied to Trump
what did they say oh Biden was
negotiable
Trump says he was too this is the same
doj that we knew held exculpatory
evidence for the Russian hoax but the
Ukraine impeachments this is the same
doj
this is our audio recordings of Donald
Trump saying these so there's a
difference the fact that you have this
privilege
Gabe go ahead Gabe and then we'll go to
Ian go ahead Gabe
right so so just this example here not
only for what Harry mentioned earlier
which is what CNN reported on which was
these conversations from the transcripts
that were more detailed of what we
already knew and then on top of that you
should have just wiped it like Hillary
let him finish
so what I'm saying is here on page 21
this is one example of this happening
right we've got text messages between
Trump and NADA we got other messages
that are happening where it is
explicitly dictated by Trump he is
trying to move these boxes and documents
around knowing full well that he should
not have these documents these
classified government documents whether
or not he [__] Declassified with his
brain is the idea that Donald Trump in
this indictment having a conversation
with attorney won an attorney too now
whether or not Rawling and Jim trustee
resigned because they're a part of this
investigation now
they told her to wipe the server and
take cameras
these are actual conversations that
Donald Trump had and except Hillary
never had the powers this is how this is
what is your argument
I'm giving you actual quotes from the
indictments
the Upstream issue is that they are
breaking two and a half centuries of
present to do this and you could do this
with everyone every single person so now
you're trying to excuse the fact that
Donald Trump took classified documents
every single president yeah so you're
you're arguing that a present like
Donald Trump should be able to take
classified documents like Donald Trump
he's the president how does that even
mean
he's not the president we're all right
guys guys
and then we'll go to Gabe and then we'll
go to prodigal please nobody interrupted
I'm only going to make one quick point
and then if if it dips below that I'll
just I'll Just Bounce the issue is is
there is the system itself is becoming
delegitimized because of the
weaponization of the justice department
here regardless of what you think of the
Merit of boxes of classified documents
every single president for the last 25
years could have been indicted by a
justice department we don't break that
precedent because the entire system
becomes delegitimized everybody knows
that lawfare can be used to take
somebody out but the Democratic process
is respected because people trust the
justice department to not get in the way
of who people vote for for president it
has to be something huge if you're going
to bring the justice department into
this classified boxes you know David
Petraeus did a did this very similar
thing and got like a a wristlet
misdemeanor as was talked about with
with uh I think it was Doc or someone
who was saying that with the uh with the
boxes I'm sorry with the server with
Hillary Clinton
and and the way she got off with growth
negligence or she that that standard was
lower every single person the Justice
Department is supposed to use a light
touch the lightest touch possible
Whenever there is some sort of
appearance of impropriety in order to
preserve in the public mind the
legitimacy of the system right now what
they're doing to Trump through lawfare
both in the New York City DA's office at
the now at the federal uh doj level and
then what's inevitably going to happen
in Georgia
you are getting half of the entire
effing country right now who's getting
the message that if you challenge this
system they even if you win even if you
win the hearts and minds and you win the
Democracy way the Crooked justice
department is going to come for you
anyway it doesn't matter how much money
you have doesn't matter how many people
think that you're right doesn't matter
how many times you win they will take
you down using the justice system and
that is what broken countries do and
that's what kills patriotism
all right so before you before you
respond to Gabe and then we'll go to
other panelists um mate actually still
with us
yeah I'm still here can you just can you
just refresh the audience on what we
know so far about the indictment just
for everyone that just joined and then
we'll continue the discussion and we got
Nick and Suleiman and Doc and others
reading through the documents to kind of
summarize it for us but if you can give
us a quick overview again for the
audience because we we got a lot of
people joined in the last few minutes
sure and I just sent it to the nest
front and center so people can read
along with me uh about 45 minutes ago
the indictment of former president Trump
in relation classified documents probe
was unsealed and we know he's being
charged with 37 federal charges
um after being indicted by a grand jury
and he will be responding to that in
Miami
um on Tuesday now counts one through 31
are for willful retention of National
Defense information count 32 is
conspiracy to obstruct Justice count 33
okay I'm gonna meet it there for a
second you want to meet yourself
um um I I don't know if Gabe can hear me
I don't think he actually can so um if
you if you're just listening we're
listening in on on the Twitter spaces um
that Mario holds
um for every for anyone who's not aware
that's what the Twitter spaces sounds
like a lot of times especially when we
go into those Twitter spaces and the
reason why they sound like that is
because they're such [__] snowflakes
right they're they're horrible at this
but they're trying this stuff out okay
that's why I go in these Twitter spaces
that's why I banter back and forth with
these fools that's why I try to break up
their narrative is because this is where
they're trying it out this is where
they're trying to work their material
and how they're going to convince the
American people that it's a good idea to
[__] elect someone who's apparently
has 30 some odd counts against them
um of seven I believe seven different
felonies that hold up to 20 years Max
per per count in some cases
um so here's the thing here's the thing
is that when you go in these Twitter
spaces again these people are trying
this stuff out and they're not really
coupled to reality right and and you
heard it there that they're just Hillary
Clinton Biden Hunter Biden laptops
emails Benghazi they just they just
can't [__] focus on a certain set of
facts and like Gabe tried to tell them
I'm reading directly from the indictment
the other thing that these [__]
chuckleheads don't understand and and
it's gonna smack them in the face but I
want to warn you it's not going to smack
him in the face right away it's gonna
take a long time to smack him in the
face
is that there's material evidence
backing up what they're saying in these
indictments right there's material
evidence now
rather that evidence proves these
charges or not that's up to a jury to
decide okay that's how it works the
Department of Justice prosecutors
collect up material evidence they
present it to a grand jury which they
did on the charges that they believe
that this material evidence
proves the crime and then once they're
indicted and they're arraigned it goes
to trial at some point if they don't
plead guilty and the jury decides if the
evidence that the Department of Justice
is going to present based on what they
believe that this proves these charges
that the grand jury indicted the jury
decides if that material evidence proves
those crimes happened okay these people
are totally decoupled from that reality
100 percent absolutely decoupled from
that reality
and they're un untethered really from
any sort of reality in that respect and
the reason why this is all going to come
smacking them in the face is because
they don't care that Donald Trump's a
criminal
they care that Donald Trump gives them
permission to be [__] [__]
they they love that Donald Trump gives
them the ability to be [__] bigots
and hate people
that's what it truly is
and the big fraud is that there's half
the country that believes this garbage
that's the big fraud half the country
does not believe that
um let's go back and see if we can um
listen in a bit more okay with that to
um or do you think he's Above the Law I
mean I just I'm just going to ask that
question
oh this is to me so when I when I
started my statement by saying is that
there has been dozens of presidents that
have done actions that have gotten them
close to the line or have gotten them in
legal trouble and there's always been a
light touch because of the fear of what
it would do to the country if somebody
who was at the level of president was
brought down by the justice system
because there's always the concern that
that if that if Justice is not blind
then nobody will have faith in it
anymore and then you start to have the
entire system come apart
you look at what was done with the light
touch with Hillary Clinton you look at
what was done with the light touch with
Bill Clinton you look at what the light
touch that was done with with with
during the Reagan Era and with and with
Bush senior with Iran Contra every
single president seems to get in some
sort of legal trouble and what's always
done is uh a way to sort of slap the
wrist or apply pressure or the person
incurs some sort of law cost but it it's
shy of of literal criminal jail time if
it left the thing is is extremely rich
and here what you're seeing is the exact
opposite of that you for example in New
York with with Bragg you and a guy who
you had you had a guy who went out of
his way this is someone who always
reduces felonies to misdemeanors for for
typical crimes and you would you had
something that was seven years old and
was essentially just a sort of you know
a campaign payment and it's 136 years
for that here you've got documents in a
box this isn't some foreign spy this is
the this is the most recent president of
the United States in a hundred years in
jail this is intentionally done they
stacked those charges
seven charges over those boxes they came
up with a big number on purpose let's go
to Andrew Andrew go ahead
I want to address what what Mike just
said because he brought up something
that I think is directly addressed in in
this indictment which is the idea that
uh other
similarly situated uh people former
presidents got what he described as
unlike touch now if you go down to count
32 uh conspiracy to obstruct
it lists the the dates of of the offense
May 11 2022 through August 2022.
and what that what that tells you is
that they are charging Mr Trump
for a conspiracy that began when he was
handed uh or his attorneys were handed
the grand jury subpoena
between that date and the eight August
2022 search of his home
and
what the indictment says is that
basically he hid and concealed these
documents from a Federal grand jury he
uh conspired to mislead his own attorney
about the presence of more classified
documents but
etc etc
so the light touch
was when he got the grand jury subpoena
and he [__] himself because instead of
owning owning up to it and giving and
honoring the subpoena giving back
everything
he [__] around
and yeah you sure know what Hillary
Clinton did you should know why yeah
exactly
yeah
and destroyed the others okay exactly
Andrew your point is totally destroyed
by that the light touch was applied to
Hillary Clinton and it was not applied
to Donald Trump and Andrew can you in
good conscience tell me that 37 separate
criminal charges for for boxing I
apologize
I'm so sorry I just shared on the nest
we have some new photos that have just
been published showing uh allegedly
showing the documents in question that
were stored in the bathroom in one of
the storage units and in the ballroom uh
we already showed these photos
if you look through the indictment
itself it's the photographs are in black
and white and a little bit like blurry
but should have been in the quarterback
but these are the um is that Hillary's
bathroom or what
the guy break the news please
they don't help right I mean I'm trying
to understand what's going on here and
you're like interrupting some [__]
some [__] joke about Corvettes guys
calm the [__] down let him report the
news and then talk about it yeah so
we've got the images
we got picture of boxes yeah so there's
so there's actually there's actually
multiple photos of boxes there's one
that's a lot hold on hold on this is
hold on two seconds this is all the
classified documents you had so this is
uh the ones that they have in the in the
actual indictment right here they have
photos that are in the locker room which
is between like a linen by a linen
closet in a liquor room as well they're
the ones that are in the bathroom where
there are text messages where we're
changing them from the ballroom to the
to the bathroom there's also the ones
that were photographed by NADA in the
office where it had spilled over and
NADA had taken photos of them so
there are multiple photos showing that
these documents were either inboxes
located in random places that could be
accessed by other people or they were in
boxes and they had spilled over for
other people to look at and and take
photos of which again shows you the the
lack of uh well I mean let's just take
it back in if you if this isn't an issue
in terms of Mike Pence Joe Biden Donald
Trump because the comparison is those
two people Mike Pence and Don and Joe
Biden we're like oh [__] yeah they've
never had authority to declassify it
doesn't matter they had these documents
and once notified then they gave them up
and said right well you can you can go
through our house you can go through our
office you can go through our any
anything that you think would help you
in terms of finding these documents that
you don't have go for it Donald Trump
and you can see it in the indictment and
even Andrew brought it up and it was a
May uh it was as of May after he got the
subpoena even before that as well there
were multiple attempts by Donald Trump
and his team directed by Donald Trump to
not get that's not right
so it's okay
is not completely right because I'm just
concerned so many boxes
a lot of
them guys this is not one file that he
left you know they brought back home in
a car yeah
and the cia's crimes against them I
don't blame them so so I've got to ask
though is returning these documents a
defense or does it negate any of the
elements of any of the crimes he's
alleged have committed because as far as
I can tell Mike Pence and Joe Biden are
equally guilty of this crime and frankly
I need to address one thing that brother
they're lawyers I agree with you because
okay so I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna come
back to um the show here and the reason
why is because if you want to go watch a
Twitter space we put the link in in the
in the chat there
um and Gabe is going to be speaking and
he's probably gonna continue to speak
he's going to continue to be on stage I
don't know how long you'll be hopefully
I'll make it on stage eventually
um and we'll get there and I I hate to
say that we didn't do the bonehead of
the week properly but it is because this
is all breaking and he's the bonehead of
the century so I just wanna I just want
to give you
um the bone of the week winner of course
it's Donald Trump of course it is
because he was the only [__]
candidate for bonehead of the week and
he's really the only candidate for
bonehead of the century okay it's just
that's just the way it is
now I I um we're gonna try I was gonna
try to stay on for three hours but I
think at this point
um it is better served if what we can do
is um go to some some other things
um and go look at news and continue to
look at this uh Gabe speaking again let
me let me go back to uh this real quick
uh and see it's the fact that when it
comes in space you know Harry mentioned
it earlier there is intent intent to
withhold to keep and and whatever the
intent is to do with these documents
after the fact but the fact that there
are time stamps we have audio recordings
video photos and also direct quotes from
Donald Trump and his team as to how to
coordinate so that other people federal
agencies won't get these documents
you're going to tell me that the
difference oh they're the same thing
they're not the same thing because if
you were to compare Penn State game
every under every element of the crime
they are the same thing Joe Biden kept
them in his garage that is interesting
and you know what and here's the thing
there is
but that's the entire thing no that's
Harry you don't know what you're talking
about because
your mic is very very very [__] loud
so that that's that's what uh happens a
lot of times in these spaces they talk
over each other they talk in and out and
it gets chaotic so uh here's what we're
gonna do and it sounds like Jack Smith
um people are saying that Jack Smith may
be on in 20 minutes is is that
um can you send me a tweet saying that
um from let's see if we get
maybe Hugo has it all right I just want
to confirm that before I say it too much
is that Jack Smith is going to be on in
about 20 minutes
um
yes uh it is
I'll see if I can find it here I want to
show you guys
um the news if I can find it
it's
um oh it's on okay
um
I'm just trying to see if I can find a
confirmation tweet of it so I can show
you guys that it is doing it and they
are telling me that yes he is going to
um he is going to speak uh so I just
want to get from a credible Source here
that he is going to speak at 3 P.M
Eastern and so it's less than 20 minutes
[Music]
um
is what he's going to speak now I'm not
going to cover that here on the show I
want to go watch that and then over the
weekend on patreon.com uh we'll we'll
cover this
um so but let me let me play
let me at least play the bonehead music
and this guy winning right Donald Trump
is the bonehead of the century let's
let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so there it is Donald Trump is the
bonehead of all boneheads of all time
um it's Insanity I know it feels like
this is uh gonna keep going oh Rachel
Rachel bittickoff or has it
um I always
trust Rachel as a source and she says
Jack Smith I'm going to retweet it here
she said Jack Smith will address the
nation at 3 pm Eastern and so I've got
um Rachel bittickoff for confirming that
for us I actually uh text Rachel earlier
she's not able to join us today
hopefully she'll be make it on Monday
man so hopefully we'll have Dr Rachel
bittickoffer on Monday about what all
the politics mean uh of all this stuff
uh that way we can get to the bottom of
that so this has been bone into the week
don't go anywhere I'm going to talk to
you for just a few more minutes uh
before we before we go away foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is a huge breaking news all day
long it'll continue into the weekend
again again I'm probably going to do a
weekend rant I might be a few I might do
a few special shows this weekend just to
let you know I
um just because this news is going to
keep breaking and breaking so if you are
a member on patreon that's where I'll
announce it so go to D Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com check out
the patreon page uh if I do them this
weekend I probably will make them public
because it's such important information
that I don't want anyone to miss but
patreon is where I'll announce it first
so that's where I'll announce any uh any
kind of lives that I do this weekend
um and we'll probably be continuing to
be Gable be in those spaces I'll be in
the Twitter spaces so don't don't forget
to catch us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
POD at the Tony Michaels and at I am
Gabe Sanchez
um even if even if you don't have
Twitter you can just go to your browser
go to twitter.com type in those handles
at I am Gabe Sanchez at D Tony Mike
vehicles and you'll see a little white
ring around our 80s it'll say that we're
in alive and then you can go listen to
it at that point even if you don't want
to download Twitter or have Twitter you
can listen to it even if you don't have
an account you can just ease drop in on
those conversations I believe you can do
that also download every single episode
including this one on Apple Spotify and
Google you can watch us live every
single weekday you can watch us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels just go
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels also or subscribe here on
YouTube while you're here don't forget
don't forget to subscribe on YouTube and
I want to thank everyone on Twitch who
watches us on Twitch every single day
and man you guys have resubbed over
there gave us some subs some Community
Subs going around over on Twitch so I
appreciate that that's great support
um uh boy it's been a hell of a week
hell of a week Pat Robinson's died yeah
that's great and Donald Trump is
indicted and this indictment this
49-page indictment is scathing
it is bad it is worse than what you
would imagine and they're still
defending him
and guess what they're going to keep
doing they're going to keep defending
him folks they're not going to stop this
stuff
it's not and I I I know people like oh
it's eventually going to go down
and they're not going to nominate them
yes they are yes they are they're gonna
do it they're gonna do it I hope you
have a great weekend again be watching
and I'll probably if I do um any kind of
special broadcast this weekend to talk
about news or to go back and watch some
clips that happen maybe me and Gabe will
do something together this weekend do
like a special edition or something on
our patreons go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez make sure you follow us there
that's probably where we're announced if
we do it public I'll probably put it on
Twitter so you guys can come take a
listen and you want to follow the
YouTube channel because that's where
I'll broadcast it maybe we'll do a
special bread we do a special broadcast
we'll broadcast across all the all the
platforms as a special presentation type
thing if we get time and stuff so be
paying attention to that I appreciate
all your support your best audience in
the world do not stop paying attention
and the one thing you don't want to do
is lay down your swords I'm telling you
they're not going to give up they're not
going to walk away from this chucklehead
and we can't walk away from the fight we
can't think we've won this this is not a
win all's this is is the beginning of
the battle because we are Trump's jury
we will convict Trump in 2024 and send
him packing that is our job it is our
mission as the pro-democracy coalition
to engage
and to find him guilty we are the jury
have a great weekend have a safe weekend
we'll see you sometime this weekend
we'll definitely see you on Monday same
time same place oh indictment week and
Raymond week next week Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon